again
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos as you
guys already know if you have watched
two or more of my lives and you do not
subscribe we have beef okay
beef people a couple announcements
before we get started so the first being
is that we have two new clips channels
one is just pearly clips that you guys
just got to 50k in a month
and we also got pearl daily in 20 days
to 10k
um
the third announcement is they took away
my first tick tock and my second tick
tock and my third tick tock but i just
got on a 100k on tick tock number four
just pearly things got more
and it's funny it's funny because they
thought they could get rid of me but as
soon as i logged in i just saw me all
over my 4u page i was like you can't you
could take me off the app but you can't
get rid of me
and my backup to that one because i am
on my final account warning on that is
just pearlythings.5
so that's at 10k so go follow that too
okay um also the memberships we have
four different memberships the first
being um you get to be a part of the
live chat some show some shows we turn
it to members only i think we're letting
them in the chat today right just
letting them in today we're letting them
in today when should we turn it off what
do you think
i'll give i'll give jess all the power
oh goodness we'll go after super chats
today we'll turn it off after super chat
yeah i was going to give it to him today
oh we'll give it to him the day no i
meant like what show should we turn it
off saturday saturday okay we'll give
you guys until saturday so sign up for
the five dollar tier so you can be a
part of the live chat ten dollar tier
you get to be a part of our behind the
scenes vlogs this penthouse is pretty
cool right guys
if you want to see what it looks like
sign up for our ten dollar membership
tier third tier you get to connect with
us on social media fourth tier you get
to do a one-on-one session with me once
a month some people use this um to get
help with youtube others to you know
tell me their problems i i can do either
but i prefer the youtube one
um anyways
um my instagram go follow that i'm
almost at 50k on instagram it's just dot
pearly things you get to see a lot of
reels so if you know they take away my
tick tock at least you can see all the
reels on um instagram
also we just hit 350k subs yesterday
yeah yeah
because we got 100k subs in the past
month
they can't
they yeah they can't stop us um our
who's our member of the week this week
did you get one
no i did not ask
do you want to pick one
can you think of one
you know you know the members usually
know the members usernames ah
i see a picture of one in my head but i
cannot think of his name you know you
want to look at like the
yeah but we'll let you guys know
tomorrow yeah
sorry
uh saturday we're not we're not always
organized
anyways um if you want to come on the
show dm eddie the link to his instagram
is in the description so
today we have a lovely panel full of
guests so why don't we go around
everyone say your name your age your
relationship status and a fun fact um do
you want to start
um my name is damayo
i'm 31 years old
uh
fun fact oh i'm the first of my name so
there's no one else called damayo but me
my parents name name made it up anybody
else called that is named after me
i'm not joking that's period
my name's hunter um 25
and a fun fat i had an alligator growing
up
that's cool wait you're an actual like a
full alligator yeah okay i'm from miami
ah okay that makes sense yeah
you know that would be legal in florida
it's like you have a permit for exotic
animals that's all right
okay
that's that's one of my funnest fun
facts i think i've had on the show
alligator yeah
alexander 27 bachelor
fun fact is i learned chinese for like
two years and went to china for a bit i
love them
um hello i am jess i am 28. a fun fact
about me oh i'm single fun fact is
oh i do not have an acl in my knee and i
found out when i tore my meniscus and
it's been torn for like one to two years
the doctor said and i played a whole
season and two three but
and help from friends help from friends
uh kit 28 um fun fact
is i have a younger sister who was born
the same day as me
i know just four years later how rude
you are
so my name is jordan i'm 28 years old
relationship status i'm engaged
fun fact
i identify as a sausage role considering
i'm going to be pissing a lot of people
off
bite me
[Laughter]
and then so say your name your age your
relationship status and a fun fact
oh okay here move the mic a little
closer to you she just got here so we're
just
yeah yeah is that close enough oh yes
hello yeah yeah i'm cat i'm 28. uh
relationship status i have a boyfriend
and fun fact i own
ten pairs of jordans oh nice yeah it's
the only thing i can think of right now
okay so um today's topic is do modern
women
deserve to be courted
so i'm going to be showing you guys a
clip
um from kevin samuels rip
um and where he talks about red flags to
look for in women
so i am just going to get you guys
reaction to it
[Music]
good old kevin
so here are some things that guys need
to watch out for
when they're dating regardless of the
size of your pocketbook or your dreams
or aspirations
ignore these things at your peril
because just like all the great men of
antiquity the bible and in the past
a woman can either help but oftentimes
the wrong woman can throw a man
completely into chaos start off with
this one she wants to be courted yeah
she wants to be courted now i know that
some guys are probably thinking hey
kevin you kind of talk like a
traditional male what's wrong with her
wanting to be courted nothing if she's
truly a traditional woman but typically
women want to be courted because they
want all the benefits of traditional
femininity in gender roles but they
bring none of that stuff to the table
this is just another way of asking you
to simp very few westernized women
deserve to be courted i say it again
very few westernized women deserve to be
courted you guys fought for equality
you're my equal you wanted equal pay you
wanted equal rights or you need to get
equal lefts you wanted to be courted
that ain't gonna happen we are equals
deal with it thank feminism one-on-one
your mamas and your grandmamas this is
the world ladies if you're watching
understand this is what men are on the
lookout for so if you're asking some guy
to court you what are you bringing to
the table other than sex and debt
she's got a 90-day rule or any kind of
rule like this in my opinion the first
time i hear a woman say she's got a 90
day rule i'm out the first time i hear a
woman talk about israel or any other
kind of rule like that i'm out just like
the united states out of policy we do
not negotiate with terrorists women can
be emotional terrorists i do not
negotiate with them because if you give
a message
[ __ ] a glass of milk she has a 90 day
rule that automatically implies to me
that she thinks her vagina is gold that
it's something that that gum important
that i have to work strive and earn for
i don't work that hard for anything that
doesn't benefit me her vagina ain't it
because if you have these 90 day rules
go out and blame all these steve harvey
type guys who told you guys this
foolishness that is man repellent rule
on day one in the other 89 days it'll be
you playing with your cat by yourself
next she's a single mother i'm not gonna
ban single mothers or anything like that
but bottom line there used to be a time
when a woman had a baby out of wedlock
it was few and far between and there was
some shame that went along with it
enough to where they didn't keep going
out and doing it over and over again now
it's a badge of honor you as a man are
worth too much and too valuable if
you've got your head on straight you're
out doing your thing
working your business taking care of
your business you should not be forced
to pick from a crop of women who've
already had another man's children you
should not have to go out here and fight
the world build such and so forth to
come home to a woman that you will at
best be the fourth or fifth most
important thing in her life you deserve
better than that i am sorry ladies if
you've had a child that is your
responsibility own it and as far as i'm
concerned stay out of the dating scene
until your kids are out of the house you
made the choice to have those children
especially if you did it outside of
wedlock if you made that choice then you
make the choice to wear that scarlet
letter it's not our problem it's yours
guys do not date single mothers do it at
your peril
next she's a strong independent fill in
the blank woman for me
you have three times to say that i'm a
strong independent blank woman i'm a
strong independent blank woman i'm a
strong independent check please i'm gone
anytime that comes out of their mouth
non-negotiable in the sense whether it's
day one or day 300
because to me that's an underlying issue
that's waiting to burst through a person
who has to say i'm a strong independent
anything is none of the things she says
just like if you find yourself having to
come into your house saying i'm the man
of this house
you got to say you're the man of the
house there's a problem if you watch
game of thrones when joffrey says i'm
the king
and tywin told him any any man who has
to say he's the king is not the king
strong independent blank anything needs
to be strong independent and alone she
believes that men and women
any species on the planet are equal we
are different for a reason i am not
going to negotiate your role and my role
if you come into this saying that we're
equal we automatically at loggerheads
because you're not a woman in my opinion
you're a female i don't date females i
date women
just like the men will hear what i'm
saying the males will probably throw
shade if you want a woman that you're
equal you're really giving your manhood
up and i can't help you for the guys out
there who are trying to hear me
equality is not what it's cracked up to
be typically women want equality when it
benefits them and they want to be ladies
when it suits them i don't have time for
all the back and forth because i'm
trying to do what i'm doing i'm leading
she's going to follow there can't be two
captains pick your poison if you pick
equality you'll die a slow death she's a
big time church girl i'm a christian i
was born and raised in the church i
attend regularly but big time church
girls tend to come with big time church
problems there's no more hypocrisy in
dating than in the church because unless
she's a big time church girl and a
virgin you're already going to have
issues
often times big time church girls try to
use the bible as a weapon against the
men that they date
to hold you biblically accountable for
everything that says a man should be but
yet not hold themselves biblically
morally or ethically accountable to
anything that it says a woman should be
they'll tend to take scriptures out of
context
use biblical stories for their own
selfish and manipulative ends and hit
you in a place to where you really can't
defend your spirituality that is the
height of manipulative deceptive bad
behavior i don't roll with big time
church bible thumpers for these primary
reasons if it doesn't suit you
move on but you know the kind of person
i'm talking about she's got lots of
single girls last thing you can cut it
now you ever see a pack of animals
[Laughter]
jesus
balls
yeah
i can still hear it i don't know why me
too
uh
there's a deposit did you pause it
blessing
oh wow sounds like charlie brown i think
you have to exit the tab on the screen
blessing
do you guys have charlie brown out here
in the uk
yeah
you know charlie brown yeah we have
charlie brown you know johnny brown
that hash brown
man's got kfc on his mind that's why
he's
okay so um i wanted to get you guys's
thoughts on that clip um agree or
disagree the whole thing so i want to
focus mostly on the beginning when he
said the courting um i thought the
church girl was funny that's why i got
to tell them
i love jesus it's so true
it's it's funny but
it's true
so do you do you think he he was
accurate or do you think it wasn't what
he was talking about and talking to your
mic
um
no i
with the courting thing i definitely
don't agree
definitely
i don't understand how you're meant to
get to know somebody if it's not through
courting but i said before like what
exactly would one define courting as
right so actually
i forgot to say this but yeah so the
definition of courting courting is the
time before a relationship starts when
the couple gets to know one another
exchange gifts and generally keep a
respectful distance with little to no
intimacy so the way i understood it is
courting is like no sex yeah i
definitely agree
yeah i definitely think that women like
there has to be a period of courting i
don't understand
other people they might not they might
feel like oh they don't want to do
quoting or dating but that's fine go
find the people that you don't want to
do it with me i can only be with
somebody who is willing to take that
time without sex as well
and get to know me on a me level and yes
go out and spend money on me as well yes
okay what do you think i'll be honest
like caught in
it doesn't have to be in my opinion like
actually going out going out for drinks
taking me out buying me fancy stuff
caught in again i do agree that they're
certain a level of like women that
should be quoted that again deserve to
be courted
and again it just depends on how you
want to get to know that person but do i
think you need to not have
sexual intercourse yeah mm-hmm at first
what do you think absolutely not
[ __ ] what the hell has any sense
she can call me what's was
equal why am i the one doing the
courting like
i will say yes when a woman takes me on
a date then i'll be like yeah yeah but
until then you're on my time
so now
okay
i i agree with what kevin samuel says
because nowadays what's courting you
talk to somebody for maybe one to two
weeks and then you have sex with them or
you meet them have sex with them on the
first day like
what what is courting nowadays when it
when does it go from courting to talking
to dating it's just like
nowadays there's really no such thing as
courting like traditional coordination
yeah do you think it's because the women
now don't typically deserve it
because they're not they're not the
things that men value anymore oh
i mean essentially yes if we're going
off of the things that men value in
women it's like
not saying that
i mean yeah essentially if men if men
want this and it would be on the flip
side if women wanted this and they're
expecting a man to have this
they would court them but it's like men
want this and
it's like a lot of women aren't having
or don't have what men want and so it's
like why would you if you're going to
buy a car you would want everything you
wanted souped up everything
everything like great in it you're not
going to buy it if it's not exactly what
you want yeah
okay what do you think kit um so we can
just establish you saying quoting is the
is the non-sexually intimate period
before
you start being you start having a
psychologist into a relationship so he
said courted like a traditional woman so
like you in the clip so what i was
thinking is the same way like they
courted in the 1950s
i mean i mean that's not happening now
and so so it says courting is the time
before a relationship starts when the
couple gets to know one another exchange
gifts and generally keep a respectful
distance with little to no intimacy so
i'd say courtney is definitely the case
aside from that last part okay as in in
terms of to zero to sexual intimacy
before relationship because nowadays
like and even girls as well nowadays
people want to have sex before they get
into a relationship with someone so they
know that they like it yeah so if if
courting is only all of that plus no
sexual intimacy
until the relationship i think that's
the difference between courting yeah no
that's not uh
yeah so recording is like without sex
and then dating is with sex no that's
not i don't think that happens yeah so
you don't you don't think modern women
deserve it well according for one oh
okay
uh
i mean if if
unless she's like unless she said modern
woman
the average
just say it bro
i don't know what you think just saying
it's unknown
like no sex in this time no it's not
happening okay well i'm i'm okay caught
in a woman but she has to display
traditional traits okay facts yeah like
so if she's a modern woman
i'm gonna wanna know just given the
given the hook-up culture state of
society that we're in i want to know
her history i want to know her sexual
history it might be too much to ask off
the bat but personally given this given
the time we live in i want to know what
her sexual history is because
if if i am having to call her
essentially no sex but the dating aspect
but i know that she's given up to men in
the past why the [ __ ] am i
why why the [ __ ] am i spending my time
money energy
on you if you've just handed it out to
people in the past it's like a it's like
a used honda civic for a bmw price
yeah so i'm not
i'm not gonna put i'm not gonna put work
in
and time and have patience that men in
the past weren't required to just
because she was able to give it up
in a certain state of emotion i'm not
willing to do that so first things first
i don't really feel like traditional
women sorry modern women deserve the
traditional type of courtship that they
did back then but
if you are deserving of it you better be
feminine you better be loyal you you
better have all of these things in place
because if like i said if i'm if i'm
having to treat you the way a
traditional man would yet you're
exhibiting nothing traditional as they
did back then and you have a [ __ ] sexual
history i'm [ __ ] gone
okay what do you think
i'm just
i just feel like it's really not that
deep okay do you know what i mean like
no
[Laughter]
why does it matter if a woman's
traditional or modern i just don't get
why because that's
go ahead no no karen no karen no because
that's
that's what men want like i don't know
what what your type is but say you
wanted xyz and a man you're not going to
go for something that you don't want and
essentially men want modern traditional
traditional women and had that have the
quality so they're going to look for
that they're going to go after that
it's like the the market dictates the
price
and so if you if you have a girl that's
more traditional more guys want her
um
typically
mean you know how everybody's been
saying modern women don't necessarily
deserve to be
courted um i would say that
the only reason
that view may be held is because women
have sex
too
willingly
and if women were more careful with how
they had sex
the price of the value of the jj would
go back to how it it would be what it
actually is as opposed to because right
now the jj has been devalued because
it's everywhere and that's why
you men can say that women don't deserve
to be courted when i don't i think all
women should be courted
if you're interested in even a hooker
yes
why would she deserve to be courted why
not because she gives it to everybody
why on earth would you wow
women are far more than their like
vagina or their sexual status
you just contradicted yourself there no
i said that the value of the jj has
reduced because women give it out so
much yeah yeah that doesn't change the
value of people that kind of implies
that the value
right but the world the world doesn't
owe you understanding so i don't the men
don't go to women and say accept me
short except me broke except me fat but
we go to them and say accept us ran
through that's not that's not a fair
deal mm-hmm why something some women
some women do accept men that are short
and broke no not not if you look at the
dates not if you look at the data men
only swipe right on or women only swipe
right on dating apps five percent of the
time five percent on the high end twenty
percent women do not accept and that's
the number one people place that people
are meeting today so women actually we
do not accept men that are short broken
fat historically even throughout all of
history most men didn't even get to
reproduce that's a privilege but can i
just okay so if a dude is broke right if
a dude is short right okay so if you're
broke you're less likely to be able to
provide for my family if you're short
you're more likely to give me kids right
if a woman is run through the her vagina
still feels good you're still going to
come
she's more likely she's more likely to
cheat or leave she's more likely to
cheat
she's more likely to she's more likely
to cheat as well no no no no no no she
no she's no she no no
okay we talked about this yeah
if she slept with more people she's not
she's more likely to cheat
and if a guy slept with more people it's
not the same
okay um
if uh because it's the thing is a dude
can be broke short and right and through
as well
right men and women are the same
either way how can a man be random but
this is the thing guys if you look at
the other side of it yeah a man
is
a woman when they have sex right a man
is coming inside of you yeah like you
end up holding on to that like sperm
doesn't just leave your body so i get
there's a certain level in terms of like
how many partners you should be with and
how accessible you are to a man and just
anyone and everyone but
i get the sense of like i wouldn't if i
was a man i wouldn't want a woman that's
just been with everyone i wouldn't want
as a woman i don't want a man that's
been with exactly and and
why do you say that a hoe deserves to be
courted
why should another dude put up with that
because if even if she she may have had
sex with other people one to be honest
let's be very very honest a hoe is
probably going to make you come faster
than a virgin
so she probably will what what you want
from her she can probably give it to you
better than a virgin can aho will
probably still be able to cook still be
able to clean still be able to educate
your kids if you're broke and you're
short you won't be able to provide and
you're not going to prove it
but the one the one thing that you're
missing is that men value loyalty and
the point that pearl's trying to make is
that she might be able to clean like you
said she might be able to cook she might
she might exhibit all of these traits
right however and she might she might
give you good sex but men value loyalty
and given her sexual status she's far
less likely to be loyal that's what men
are aiming for it's the thing is right
like that is still uh
that's still like a a maybe she might be
less loyal it's also equally
she
said okay you said you said you saw my
tic tock right oh yeah i said like you
said you were you were before the show
you said you were triggered by my tick
tock yeah you're not triggered you were
upside down you were you felt some type
i felt that you have a platform and you
sometimes you're irresponsible with the
things that you say
mm-hmm do you know which thing upset me
the the five body count one no no no
okay when you when a girl said that she
spent her twenties finding yours herself
and you said what does that mean you
don't spend but so many women
have to take time finding themselves you
were raised in a really beautiful home
with a beautiful family with five older
brothers that looked after you not
everybody i've ever brought them i don't
know
but you've had
you had siblings that helped you build
character and helped you feel
comfortable with who you are not
everybody has that same footage i
understand that but the point is the
world doesn't owe you understanding so
yeah no but you are when you're saying
that like you deserve to be courted by
someone like the key word is deserve
nobody deserves anything you know i can
ask you can ask questions sorry paul go
ahead um so imagine you've got two guys
right you've got one guy average high
average looks average income right
they've got the second guy right tall
good looking confident intelligent
clearly there's one guy you you want
more and there's one guy who's seen as
more valuable to you because of what you
look for than the other right so would
you be expected right because it's gonna
be harder to get him
yeah right would you be expected to the
same degree
the same level of effort that you put in
to get his attention to connect with him
right would you expect to have the same
level of effort for the guy that you
find less valuable you're going to have
to redirect the question because i don't
chase
yeah but it's not about chasing but
you're making an effort to put effort
into no hold on hold on hold on you
don't put effort in with guys at all
can i just ask what's your relationship
have you
read blind man love [ __ ]
no no i would say if you had a boyfriend
you would have said that
who heard you like
what was
so basically if i just put in a mutual
amount of effort so if that's that
intelligent whatever guy that's there he
can be there and they can be the average
guy if the average guy is building more
of a relationship with me or making more
effort with me that's who so you don't
you don't reciprocate in dating no i
only reciprocate i don't i'm not going
to
so how are you supposed to let him know
you're interested you don't instigate
basically yeah exactly i don't instigate
it
because that's what he's saying if you
had two men in front of you how would
you like how are you going to choose
you're automatically going to change i'm
not going to want a guy that wants me to
chase him okay so
it's not about chase and that's my point
if you have two opportunities like both
of them don't know about each other and
you're speaking to them both you're
automatically going to choose the one
that is more suited to you like you're
not going to choose the one just because
of well unless you care more about
personality depending on what your
values are i do care more about
personality well that's what i'm saying
so how do you choose and he's saying
like how would you do that so if you're
the last woman on earth you decide you
decipher the value but let me quickly
ask you a question so just just a little
look into a man's brain right regardless
what any man wants to say
men off the bat we want to have sex
right so you said previously that every
single woman should be caught with the
same okay everyone should be caught with
the same so if a man was to call a woman
say over three months hypothetically
the man was caught a woman over three
months
he spent his time money resources all of
his energy on you do you believe
once he's done that
you owe him sex no i don't believe i owe
him anything but if i want to have sex
with him i'll have sex with him
but he has to do
all this stuff
for you that's the biggest thing you're
not doing anything
for him i
i'm not going to do anything for him
i said i said that women deserve to be
courted so i think that all women
deserve especially and i think as well
it's the intention that you have for the
woman so if you're dating women to find
your like life partner
then yeah then definitely you should
take time to court them properly if
you're dating women to [ __ ] then call
date women
to [ __ ] but even
so even the women that say oh men are
trash men are xyz men don't deserve this
from me men don't need this from me i'm
a like uh kevin samuel says i'm a
independent woman i can do things on my
own like
why why do they need to be courted if
they can do it on their own they can
take their selves out to them they can
take their self they can court
themselves essentially why do they why
do they deserve to be courted if they're
not essentially going to give
reciprocate the
reciprocated for the man so the thing is
for me right i feel that relationships
and you're probably all gonna attack me
for this but it's what i feel and what i
believe i feel relationships marriage
is more advantageous for men than it is
for women i feel that men need women
more than women need men
and
because of that
men should make more effort
and like
yeah even if those women that feel that
men are trash men are this or
all of those types of women they can
either choose to be single and they'll
be happy or if a man wants them that man
should work to prove them wrong and
work to have them on their side awesome
okay i have so okay so
how do how do everyone's like
how do women how do men you said women
or men need women more than women need
men yeah how is that true when they want
everything that in society what do you
mean everything the power supply the
emphasis the entire infrastructure of
society oh it's it's very simple it's
because construction needs sex more than
women need sex but can i just quickly
say that's all you offer
who offers that's all you offer that's
all women that's all okay not all i
offer because
i i mean you just said you just said you
would do nothing for a guy right but so
when you don't have to when when you say
that's not that's not all you offer
generally speaking the things that you
believe you offer a man we point blank
don't give a [ __ ] about yeah you can
offer personality you can offer the
ability to clean the house unless you're
loyal and the puss is good we genuinely
don't give a [ __ ] more than any so
basically i know all men really care
about is
sex basically in the beginning yeah all
men care about is sex and every woman
has the ability to give a man sex
basically and so what do women need from
men
okay so protection protection
provisioning
from what sustainability suitability
wait pause protection from what
if someone breaks into your house who
who who protects you
the people police
[Music]
are men or men
do men not do men not run the police
department the fire department all this
no no those are those are men in society
i'm talking about men in your
relationship so okay so
it's important it's not in society okay
so then okay so then in regards to that
right right because it's important to
distinguish the difference between the
two
men don't need women for a relationship
either we don't need each other today
the whole reason people paired up back
in the day was for survival
right but we live in a modernized
society now where we don't need each
other for survival right it's not like
oh like you said if a burglar comes in
you're calling the police
right and all of this so men need women
i just i just don't know what
actually i have a question i have a
question
what what does a guy get from a woman
that he couldn't get from a cook a
cleaner and a hooker
[ __ ] oh probably
no no no you're right probably and if
it's just the woman with relationship
definitely it would be loyalty and the
stability of that woman your cook
couldn't leave she might say oh she
needs all of those people there's no
it would be the stability and the
loyalty definitely i'm not saying any
that that's not wrong right and that's
but that goes back to like why it's
better to date girls with lower body
counts because they're more loyal
yeah but that's i don't i don't know
about all of that so if a girl doesn't
if a girl is a virgin if a girl is a
virgin on her wedding night she has an
80 chance of a happy marriage if she
sleeps with more than five people it
drops down to 30 percent but that
doesn't mean the man's gonna stay there
how many men women women leave most of
the time it's 70 to 80 percent of the
time
if you're if you're college educated
it's 90 and they cheat at similar rates
and there's actually studies that have
come out recently saying that women
cheat more than men because think about
it we have way more opportunity we walk
down the street say hello to a man he's
down women have fallen
it's a woman's choice to be single and
it's a man's choice to be in a
relationship 100 right however if a man
cheats yes this is that's like maybe
that the females obviously cheat more
society is changing things are changing
women want to show that we're the
masculine ones which is why we're
demasculating the matter who cares yeah
but what you're talking about i'm saying
like like why does that why are you
giving them an excuse it's not an excuse
it's not an excuse it's like it's facts
in my opinion so if women want to become
this masculine power but i'm saying you
just said you said a statement you said
that like men are the ones cheating i
said no recent studies have said that
women are the ones cheating and now
you're changing the subject
i'm talking about specifically if for
example a virgin she doesn't know any
much different depending on her
loyalties
stuck with loyalty and i'm saying that
doesn't mean they'll have a happy
marriage going back to your specific
point which is why i point out men cheat
i'm not saying that every single one but
i think like as adults
as adults in a conversation like yes
they're going to be exceptions but if
you have an 80 chance isn't that better
than a 30 chance and if you were a dude
you pick the you pick the the 80 chance
and second off the other problem is like
a lot of times what girls will do is
they'll give it to the last guys for
free and then try to like they're used
honda civic and trying to require bmw
prices but you can't go back to being a
new bmw i do agree after a certain
period of time sex means nothing to
people like sex doesn't mean anything
it's not valued i do agree but that's
why i mentioned earlier if a woman is
going to be valued to be courted
she needs to be
like she can't just be accessible to
anyone you have to have a high press
value on yourself 100 in this society
because things are not the same
the funny thing is
i want to go back
it's 14 of our girls are virgins at the
age of 25 if you're wondering i want to
go back to something you said earlier so
you said um
men
men need women and women don't need men
earlier you were talking aware when
pearl was asking us about kevin samuels
and courting you had said
oh yes i do think women should be
courted because i want a man to buy me
nice things a man to treat me like this
but if you don't if men
don't need if women don't need men then
why would you need a man so there's a
big difference between need and wants i
don't need a dude but yeah i would want
somebody to buy things that i don't want
to buy for myself definitely and um
oh wow you know you know
why don't you want to buy it for
yourself i i well
it depends you see i don't know
why do you want someone where's the
desire develop that you actually want
someone to buy something for you though
if you can get it for yourself just it's
not just buying things that's really
superficial it's not just buying things
like but
there's a difference between wanting a
partner and needing a partner and most
women want a partner for various
different reasons like to be part things
but that's what we bought things yeah to
to have somebody to cuddle at night to
have somebody to talk to have somebody
to build things with and men don't need
them
no no no but men need women men need
women to build legacies men need women
to have stable partnerships with what
men need women to have sex with women
okay
what you're saying is correct then why
did only 40 of men reproduce
historically and 80 percent of women did
wait so i'm saying
40
of men reproduced historically 80 of
women did so who needs who more because
men historically more men have lived
without women than women have lived
without men yeah not in my own in not in
my world so yeah but your world is not
really close to the reality i yeah but
can anybody hear my mic yeah
i'm looking live this is all sounded
like it's in your world yeah
yeah that's fine
i want to ask you a question go back to
what you said previously so you said
every single woman deserves to be
courted then you also said that if a man
and a woman want to date and have sex
which is different they can right do you
believe dating can lead to a
relationship and sustainability yeah so
why the [ __ ] a man caught in you if
you can [ __ ] date you and then get
into a relationship long term anyway
well i think it's part of a man like
putting in the effort that needs to be
put in but he can do that from dating
he can do that don't lose just caution
with sex we've established that so if a
man can date you i.e courtship and have
sex and can lead to a relationship why
is a man going to spend all of his
emotion time and resources so for me as
a woman right so for me as a woman
literally only fifty percent of women
have ever orgasmed right
it's for men
google it
talking about orgasms yeah it's like he
asked you he asked you one question
because i'm getting back to his question
because okay for me as a woman i'm not
going to just start dating and sleeping
with a guy because one
like the sex on my heart will is more
for you more for the guy than it is for
the woman you're definitely going to
come i'm might not i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry i do yes i do i'm
sorry i understand on a personal level
that's how you feel but the truth is
overall i see relevant get back to the
question i said if a man that's what you
said i've gone back on your statement
right if a man can date you right you
have sex and caught you separate to just
caution you i'm telling you because why
am i going to just be having sex with
you
when it could not when it might not go
anywhere and then you're going to
complain on the other hand that oh your
body count is high i don't want you why
am i going to what but
the point is that could happen but
you're looking at it from a woman's
point of view yeah
right yeah but like the problem is you
don't look at things from men's point of
view i don't want to
[Music]
i read faster so
okay but traditionalism is valued in
women because it shows how she values
herself and her body if you
indiscriminately give your body away to
everyone it's not special anymore what
makes anyone think a hoe would make
moral or sound choices for their man and
their kids or not divorce him that's
true can i ask you a question wait so if
that's true then why would he quote her
no but then you know the funny thing is
right
one
hoes can be very smart a lot of hoes are
very intelligent we don't give a [ __ ]
yeah
i know you don't have to give it to me
all you give a [ __ ] about is
is sex
and loyalty and the whole will probably
give you sex and she can lie about being
loyal if a woman tells you her body
count is zero and she's a virgin
that's that's what you're going to
believe so no no no no
men aren't stupid they know if you've
been single a long time
they know if you're over a certain age
like i mean i i hear i hear i hear guys
like that they like i'm friends with a
lot of guys in these spaces that give
dating advice to men and they said yeah
if a girl says she's over 25 and a
virgin don't believe her if she's been
saying that's not true though i know 25
year olds that are virgins okay okay
well they could say that but i don't
know i know that's virgins
what type of
vibrator you recommend to your friends
and like the group of people that
subscribe to this dead
because i know there's a favorite brand
i know they have a group chat and
they're like yo the maestro [ __ ] master
3000 is [ __ ]
way better than these men
yeah that's true okay
ask a question back to courting right
in your eyes right outside of
personality do you see men having
different value in terms of their
romantic potential to you so do you see
some that have higher some have lower
you don't know them personally but you
seem some is higher and lower
but not every and not every man is seen
as equal in your eyes are they
um
to be honest
i am somebody who really just i can it's
mainly just personality no no i'm saying
outside of personality so i'm like for
example like if if a matchmaker came to
you said we've got 10 guys this is what
it is on paper
some you would rate higher than others
wouldn't you based on women i would
probably rate bombs low okay yeah
exactly okay so you rate guys at
different values right do you understand
that men do the same for women yeah of
course okay
so do you think courting
is deserving of the highest value woman
or the higher value he sees her the more
he caught her i'm just asking a question
no yeah i can do you think the higher
value he sees a woman the more he should
call her
probably yeah okay but the funny thing
is so there's some women to a guy's eyes
right if he sees his courting is
reserved for the highest value woman in
his eyes there'll be some women that he
sees that's not worth courting yeah
definitely of course okay that's all
we're saying no i know when people say
she's for the streets
they don't wanna exactly no but i hear i
hear everything you guys are saying okay
but it doesn't change the fact that a ho
whatever you define as a hoe
is deserving of courting and she will be
courted by someone who she might not be
quoted by you but trust me but not that
like she's getting taken out yeah yeah
than most virgins a lot no no no
probably more premium men than most
people okay okay so so you're right on
some level hoes do a very good job of
hiding it a lot of the time and they do
end up getting married a lot of the time
but the issue and i've asked a lot of
older people this like i've asked people
like in their 40s 50s like what happens
to the hoes they get married eventually
they say yeah but they're the first
divorced
so
so they leave can i i want to go back to
like what you said about how virgins are
80 more likely to stay uh
yeah well they're more likely to rate
their marriage as happy after ten years
oh so it's actually happy because that's
that's a big question are they actually
even happily married well all you can do
you know they say believe women so if we
ask them and they say they're happy
do you not believe women
so this is false
no my question would be seriously are
they actually happy after but we believe
women here so yeah if they say they're
happy that's really cool sorry just
i still don't think i've got an answer
to the question though which question so
it sounds it sounds to me at this stage
that i know you're speaking on behalf of
women but it sounds that's what you said
but it sounds like am i no she does not
i'm speaking on behalf of
you've said that you're speaking on
behalf of women it sounds to me like
you're speaking more on behalf of
yourself i am i've never said i was
speaking on behalf of well that's one
but so let's go back to my original
question okay you said every woman
deserves to be called okay yes
now if a man my own opinion right but if
a man in you but you've also said
courtship obviously being dating without
sex but you've also said that women and
men can date and you've you just agreed
recently
a man and a woman can it can lead to a
relationship if a man and a woman has
sex uh while they're dating so why the
[ __ ] is a man gonna waste all of it why
is a man gonna waste all of those all of
those resources that time and energy on
calling you with no guarantee of six at
the end when he can just date you have
sex at the same time and get the same
loyalty and sustainability at the end so
he can date someone else and have sex
because if you're going to court me
we're not going to have sex because i'm
not going to just sleep with you you've
just gone back on your statement yeah
but then like why wouldn't he just i'm
trying to answer your question he's
saying why have you gone back earlier
because you said that someone who can
date you and have sex but you're saying
me but that's what i'm saying in general
okay
you you can't date me and just have sex
and it and i will hope that one day it
releases a relationship right that can't
happen quite respectfully respectfully
forget you for a second i'm talk that's
why you're saying that's why people yeah
that's why women in general yeah you can
date and it can lead to a relationship
for other women but the reason why i
don't think that's right is because that
can is not a hundred percent so
i don't think it's right
it's not 100 that's going to lead to a
relationship to marriage yeah
it's not 100 of the dating is going to
lead
to marriage
that's fine i'm not going to just let
you take me out and sleep with you
that's fine and then
yeah
i'll do it but that's fine but at the
same time it's also not a guarantee that
a man will get six at the end of
courtship so it sounds like you want to
have your cake and eat it yeah
that was actually that's just
what she's been saying for like 20
minutes i don't know
and the thing is right yeah because a
man should be putting in more effort and
should be risking more because men need
women more than women
that's not true but that's not true
you can feel it
but you can you can you can okay okay
okay you got it you got to stop over
talking me you can you can feel it but
if historically 40 percent of men have
reproduced so the majority of men have
lived without women always can i ask if
let's just go back before you skip you
just were saying that
this is what you feel should be like you
don't want to you're hold out from sex
you'll hold out you'll hold up but you
expect you this you expect this you
expect this but now today like society
women just give out sex and so and
that's why i said the value of sex and
the value of vagina is in the ground
because women give it out the point of
the matter is so let me finish here the
point of the matter is
you're talking about why women should be
courted and the whole debate is why
women shouldn't be basically like
because we're not deserving of it and
what type of women should be
and you're saying you want to be and
that's fine but that we're talking about
debate about society about women in
general like why i wish women would
fight that's fine but you can't believe
speaking about that think about why
women should be better for themselves
okay okay you know everyone
but
but the problem is you can't just raise
your value for if you've given it out
before like you want to be courted like
a virgin but if you're not a virgin how
can you ask for virgin prices you can't
put a higher price tag on what you've
given yeah like so so you can't just say
you can't just say i am valuable like i
could say i'm a billionaire it doesn't
make me a billionaire so if you're not a
virgin anymore you can you can say give
me virgin prices but if you're not but
if you're not a virgin you can't just
magically become one i think i think i
think she actually i think she actually
agrees because you literally just said
right you're just like every
you wish women you said the value of
vagina is in the ground right because
sex is giving out too easily for a bunch
of women
right so you're saying you feel you
deserve you feel that women deserve to
be courted
if they were going to raise the value of
vagina if they acted well
right so in actual fact so you're
actually agreeing saying that the modern
woman today
right on average is lower value so then
she actually doesn't deserve but the
thing is right the value of vagina can
never ever go down because men will
always decide
no no no but it's only down because it's
not a zero yeah it's only down because
it's so readily available if women all
of a sudden if the government put into
place that no man can have sex until he
puts down 100k deposits
what do you think men would do
they would uh
and you can't make you younger like you
can't you can't just raise someone's
value you can't make you younger you
can't make you more pure there's new
girls turning 21 every single day can i
give an example please guys honestly
this is an experience of a lifetime but
when a woman and this is the thing is
there's a real life storyline i know the
situation
40 years old yeah has 12 kids
completely yeah it's cool but a man does
want her but you don't want him
i wasn't even finished
do you think like after or someone's
been used that many times how'd they
make kids
those aren't even your kids don't be
stupid of course no it's not about being
stupid this is not that seriously no
it's not
do you want to be with a man that has 12
kids 12 baby mamas
that's that's a drama
that's drama it is wrong yeah so the
same goes with a man after a woman has
put herself in so many situations do you
think any man's gonna want her it's
debatable 100 people still get a man
okay for no no for four sex
you will you will find somebody you will
stop cutting me off stop cut it stop
you will find somebody that wants to
sleep with you but marry you cooked
cooked and you don't deserve it and you
don't just like why would you deserve
that
you want your brother to court a girl
that has 12 kids can i quickly ask so
you said a man will date her i agree but
the type of man who is going to be
willing to date you as a man you're not
going to want to stick with long term
because
from my perspective only a complete
[ __ ] [ __ ] a complete symp
but long term you're not going to want
to stay with that bloke at the end of
the day i think you just need to stop
being delusional admit that your used
goods
i think that's really it that woman
would be used goods
100 but but
her question was would a man want her
you know what actually yes actually you
know what i imagine you always want a
woman
no that's not no matter the
circumstances
a woman will always find a man person to
commit no no no first she can find a man
to even to even what is committed be
with her but
she's willing to now settle with no no
no no no no look i'm asking you the
question because like let's let's say
for example you're not going to accept
that women don't have no listen look
let's say let's say for example you're
right like let's say i agree with you
and that a man will want to get with you
right
what chance do you truly have in wanting
to stick with that man long term
because i'm i'm giving you i'm giving
you a quick look into the into the male
brain right now i'm telling you now a
man is not going to want to be with a
woman who's for i don't know who's 40
years old with 12 kids if he does want
to date you long term i'm telling you
now he is a [ __ ] [ __ ] he's got no
back well but you're not going to want
to be with him so what's the point of
getting to relationship if any of the
pieces
also we have we have a 50. we have a 50
super chat i read these right away i
read these right away the the value of
vagina can never go down but it only but
it's only down today because it's given
away so readily hoes can't hoes can be
educated hoes can be educated but that
doesn't mean she's smart the
contradiction shows it's very evident
the hoe in blue is educated but lacks
common sense goddamn
i would say you know what actually you
know what no i i agree with that i agree
with her right and the reason i agree
with her yeah is because there are way
more desperate men out there i agree
yeah he's completely right he's
completely right like the guy who's
actually going to go for that kind of
woman
is not going to be it's not going to be
any man any woman wants can we watch you
always have an option can we talk about
a different side of it right we want to
talk about sex sex sex vagina vagina
do you know how much trauma that woman
has
let alone you just want do you that's
what i'm saying do you think anyone
wants her that type of woman has been
through abandonment abandonment
abandonment but you know you need to
understand how much men will always want
yeah but there's a difference right the
type of man you're gonna get someone
who's very manipulative controlling or
is messed up ahead he's tapped well he's
actually tapped and why wouldn't he just
go somewhere else
yeah there's other girls that can give
him sex so you you can say you're
getting one 40 year old with 12 kids
okay so here's
that
no but her mentality is is excellent for
someone who can like motivate three or
fours because imagine the kind of
motivation you can give people if she
was on the street corner just motivating
hoes telling them no listen you got a
[ __ ] someone's going to want
the thing she's like the steve harvey
opposed i'm sorry right should i tell
you the truth right i read
this level of i love i love your idea of
like women have this infinite value but
you're also they're also divine by the
fact that they have a [ __ ] and that
that value isn't kind of shaken by
anything and everything is valued by a
no because the only reason i don't think
because
i meant to find out i know that sex
right is probably the last thing on the
list that's why i don't need to out
that's why i will insist on courting
before anything else from your
perspective yeah i'm talking i can only
talk from my perspective i can't talk
from anyone else's perspective
but
men right
all men care about is sex the man you
know no no he's the one that said no i i
disagree he's
the men you know only care about sex but
men men want wives they want people to
raise their children it's not only sex
we want sex but we want purity and we
want loyalty and you in youth you know
what's funny i've always been told a man
can tell if a woman is a wife material
and you can't
i can see if a woman's wife material you
can tell
how she cares of her values and that's
why some women i don't think they
deserve to be caught in because i'm like
you you're just giving yourself out
there you're disrespecting yourself why
do you expect anyone to respect you see
what you just said
men can tell when a woman's 100 that's
why they disrespect you because you're
disrespectful men also have a radar for
hose hundred percent i know when a host
tells her when she slips around any
sense it's just buddy
people move themselves see them girls in
the clubs that are always trying to be
around the man always trying to be doing
this trying to get their attention just
chill like the man will come to you but
you're just trying to go near them
because you're dying for the attention
men don't find that attractive
so they don't smart man don't find it i
feel like we're smart i feel like we're
beating the dead always at this point
yeah yeah yeah i just want to know like
what your routine of self-worship is
like do you do you look at yourself in
the mirror tell you the truth right okay
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa you just said hold up wait wait
wait did you just say every woman here
is a pick me more or less not you oh no
no no no no no
wait wait wait wait how is
how is understanding
how the other species
operates and how what they value what
they want how is understanding them a
pick me when we always say wait wait
wait when we always say that they need
to understand women they need to
understand women it's like how are you
supposed to be in a relationship with
someone you when you get in a
relationship with friends you try to
understand your friends who and you want
them to understand you so you can grow
that relationship you can be the best
friend they have in that relationship
how are you going to be one-sided and
say oh we don't need to understand man
we don't need to know this about men
they need to understand us and how we
operate and that's a pick me if we try
to understand how they operate to be
able to have a good relationship to not
be single at 40 with 12 kids to not die
alone with a dog how is that a pick me
well [ __ ] sad
think that they're understanding or
they're
like are they not human no no of course
they're human but you think that it is
like
it's truth it's gospel it's like
determining the facts like i i cannot
accept that
uh you think that's what's true
what's true like what's the gospel you
you saying that oh um certain women
don't deserve certain things like
because that's their perspective and
their understanding
we all must now accept that as it's it's
a choice it's choices have consequences
and if you and if you choose and if you
choose to make certain decisions the
consequences that most men will not want
to court you and the ones that do you
will not like
so do you you believe that every single
woman should be caught with i do right
you think they're entitled to that yeah
so then do you believe because we're
talking about equal exchanges right so
if you believe all women deserve to be
courted
why do men not why are men not entitled
to sex at the end of it
at the end of being courted well yeah
it's a man
sex
is a person's life
sex the point of sex is actually to
bring life into the world okay but it's
been reduced the value of sex is far
more than
courting no
point it's women in the 90s women women
women
stop over talking me you've done it so
many times or so you need to stop doing
it women in the 1950s deserve to be
courted because they were virgins why on
earth would a man court a girl that's
not a virgin nowadays when you've given
it to other men for free why like i said
at the beginning if the point of it is
to have good sex someone who's already
had sex is probably going to give you
better sex than a virgin
yeah yeah that makes sense
you um where you said they're like wait
wait but then wouldn't he want it now no
no no
so then why would he court her wouldn't
he date her thank you very
why would much wait for that okay and
then i will say well he could go down
the street and talk to rebecca and then
i would say who's down now
and then i will say who's also 25 years
old without 12 kids yeah go down the
street and talk to rebecca and have and
have sex with her straight away and
whatnot and then decide what it is that
you're looking for are you actually
looking for someone who's going to raise
your home and raise your children and
look after your home properly
and if you are then you should take time
to look at that person look at their
values
understand them properly
and spend time and money on them without
sex
let me i think how is it
eliminating sex get you to that end how
does eliminating sex
i think i think one uh sex does like um
it it frogs judgement for women not men
i
think as a woman yeah so so i'm talking
from a woman's perspective because
but i'm not asking you i'm asking you
from their point of view i don't know
men's point of view we're telling you
we're talking about points
but you're saying you don't care from
men's point of view why on earth would
they court you if you're not a virgin
why would they wait for sex
when it's not even guaranteed at the end
spend money when it's not nothing is
guaranteed to them exactly because
you're saying you're saying that you're
saying that [ __ ] has the most value the
fact that matter is a man is spending
his time energy and resources that he
has to attain to get the [ __ ]
why is the [ __ ] any more valuable let
me make a point based on what i said
earlier you said for example that all
were meant to be called great i said to
you earlier if a woman is devaluing
herself and disrespecting herself and
i'm sure you know girls i know girls
that just are out there and they're
married yes
now out there boy yeah wait where's my
friend anyways you're worried again let
me finish my point your word so let me
finish my point so as i was saying so
those women that are disrespectful
to themselves and just throwing
themselves out there like i said a man
can tell a wife material you can tell
you can take on one first day doesn't
mean you have to caught her and take her
out take her out take her out what are
you doing with her
you should know from that first initial
reaction i should know all right cool
what's this person about do i actually
like this person spend your time asking
the the right questions if that's what
your goal is
only men that actually want a woman
they'll ask the right questions if they
just want to have sex with they're just
going to take you out and have sex if a
man is not going to stay
right yeah but most women do that
nowadays you're saying you don't but we
all know women out there that just give
it out and that's the point so most
women don't deserve water and simple as
unless you bring your value
his time and energy on you over time you
owe him sex at the end of that you
absolutely owe him sex you owe himself
you're putting a value on sex and it
does not you're the one who just said it
was the most valuable
i truly believe you don't know where the
[ __ ] you are right now what do you mean
i believe you don't know where you are i
believe you've dug a hole so deep you
can't get out you're trying to fight
you're trying to scratch yourself to go
deeper and deeper i don't think you know
where you are okay wait it's super super
chat really quick i read that i read
this mic
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait stop
stop stop okay um james ryan do you only
keep these people on the show for
content all her tics show that she is
not going to listen and will never
listen because she already has an
established position it's a social media
trap and you have to be what your
audience wants okay that's it can i
a question is there any older women who
have the same mindset as you none that
you know
no
there isn't no so you know you said a
lot of your whole friends are married
right
are there any women who are maybe more
like you are they married as well or
what results are they getting
yeah actually i have some friends like
me that are married that are married as
well okay lucky i was just a bridesmaid
at one wedding okay so um
alex has a presentation for us
well
i mean go on alex i think this would
work really well on you actually
oh um is this a magic trick no no no
you go grab it go grab the white board
so alex made
yeah um
so before the show um alex was here
and he came up with a presentation on
how he dates modern women
[Laughter]
yeah yeah so we we got a whiteboard guy
thank you for the donations to get us a
whiteboard
also we also bought blessing a chair
it hasn't come in yet though so let's
talk all right so if you could yeah yeah
so if you could if you could zoom in you
know give them give them okay
okay
thank you
i've got a couple of things that i'd add
to that though alex yeah okay yeah
you're not truly fleshed out but this is
just the basics
sorry what'd you say
if she could move
wait oh okay would you move to that mic
really quick just just while he does the
presentation okay so yeah i was asked
what my general approach to modern
dating is
uh and i came up with this kind of this
general infrastructure it's generally
how it goes all right
so obviously the modern woman
is generally a narcissist generally like
they're generally addicted to energy
attention and so the first step is to
ignore gas like this woman right so you
ignore her because it shows your high
value
and you guys like her by by kind of
alternating between the alpha she wants
and the beta feminism tells us she wants
right so you've got to be a badass but
also emotional and kind of vulnerable
but also ignore this woman or she will
lose interest
in
it's a bunch of things but generally if
you fail at stimulating the modern
woman's limited attention span you lose
so
you have to kind of flip between the
alpha debater because they want they all
want the top guy but they want that top
guy to need them that's better ship so
so you know if i was if i was a six foot
three athlete with a six foot job why
the [ __ ] would i want you like are you
that special you're not but i have to
convince you you are right
why do you have to convince us that we
are because
[ __ ] has infinite value right you don't
chase i chase you because you're a queen
you know that anyway so alpha beta you
gaslight right
um
you have to do at least these two and
flip between alpha and beta step two you
get the contact details right so the
female has been uh properly stimulated
you're like uh you know let's get your
number instagram
you talk to you whatever
you have to keep this up this that one
never goes away constantly it's the
fandom you gotta do that when you're
married you've got to go to your
freaking coffin doing that right am i
gonna die who knows
that's sexy watch any movie the guy is
like i might pass away any time now he's
leaving notes and [ __ ] this dude just
doesn't want to die he's just [ __ ]
gaslighting her right so step two you
get the contacts and you emotionally
babysit so because of limited attention
she has these knees right so by
emotionally babysit i mean you've got to
kind of help her grow emotionally she's
probably be hurt by some loser um and
you're going to be one of those guys but
for now you've got to kind of sell or
trauma unpack all that stuff ask all
these cheesy questions no one really
cares about what was your last
relationship like do you value love uh
what kind of girl are you what kind of
guys she doesn't care what you liking up
so
a lot of you guys in this stage [ __ ] up
because you're telling her stuff about
you she doesn't care i've never heard a
woman be like i met this guy and he's
really interested in architecture she
doesn't care
she doesn't care all she heard was your
job title and she saw how you looked in
your general physique
that's it listen bro you drive exactly
so you mostly babysit this period takes
one to three weeks because obviously you
know you can't answer too frequently
you've got to give a time you know the
gas lighting and the ignoring is
important you've got to make it feel
like you might ignore the text um never
reach too far you know make statements
don't ask questions or too many
questions and if you do ask a question
make sure it's something she obviously
wants to talk about like how sexy she is
her value in a long-term relationship
all that kind of [ __ ] that actually
doesn't mean anything but she probably
tells herself that every night so
you do that one to three weeks has
passed now you're going for the kill
right
invite her on maximum few days this is
my role you guys you simps can do 100 if
you want but
i do three dates
date one
cold clothes because you're still
gaslighting this [ __ ] right how could
you let her know you kind of want to
shagger don't don't let anybody don't
give her that power she's gonna get gas
so you guys like her you know you're
still kind of flipping between alpha
beta
second day you gotta close because you
know we all got jobs and stuff you got
we got stuff to do right so you try and
close
if that fails you go back to step one
and repeat
if that succeeds
i've got this pitch right so now
what you do is it lasts for about four
weeks you know now you're kind of just
you know texting and hooking up
generally
but you've got to tease a long-term
relationship at some point because you
know she's going to convince herself if
you've made it this far she probably
could see yourself with you right but
obviously i'm just here to shark so i'm
just trying to you know i'm trying to
keep it going as long as possible so it
lasts about four weeks and then she's
kind of okay i've noticed this kind of
lines it links up with the menstrual
cycle the next menstrual cycle she's
going to be like do i need this guy man
you know of everything generally so
after about a month things are going to
get shaky you tease a long-term
leadership oh you know
what do you want i'm not sure yet i know
what i [ __ ] want i want a shag i
wanted a shag this whole time in a month
i'm gonna want a shag it doesn't change
but you tease that yeah and you don't
have to do it too hard don't try too
hard just say stay less less is more
right because then she'll just you know
she'll
figure out herself you know she'll think
what she wants to think and then you
repeat but generally you know everyone
has a shelf life she normally kind of
the smarter ones tend to kind of fade
away quicker
um but some of the smart ones last
longer those are the best but um
step four as you guys so when you end a
relationship with the modern woman
because the narcissist you really don't
want to give her any ammunition because
she will [ __ ] about you to everyone so
what you've got to do is you just go
cold turkey you just stop if you explain
what she will tell people is the things
you just told her explain which is going
to be [ __ ] because we all just want
to [ __ ] so she's going to tell other
people that and then there's going to be
rumors and there's going to be all this
energy i don't want to give you that
ammunition so
i'll just ghost you yeah i'll just like
just
why why explain anything is she going to
listen to your nod like
i get that i wouldn't be with me either
she's not so what's the point is she
going to take your critique absolutely
not she's probably a modern woman she
probably thinks she can do it too
she's probably going to tell you that
like you're some [ __ ] you were
abusive or manipulative or or some kind
of gas like i would kind of work like
listen yeah it's modern times
um so that's generally the
infrastructure um it's a lot more
complicated than this class any
questions
um i have a question yeah i have one
today i have a question first date right
first date
right do you take us our fancy would you
keep it cheap
listen
this is a system right
and every system has limitations in this
case it's it's time which is obviously
everyone's limitation but it's also
money b in fact i'm doing this for four
or five [ __ ] at the same time do you
think i made the money that's what i'm
saying i think i'm going to take you out
to top restaurants thank you with no
guaranteed sucks are you dumb
are you stupid
you think you're that special
so you'd agree that if you spend these
resources and time and energy then she
should be giving you success you know
what i mean nothing is guaranteed
nothing is guaranteed in life which is
why we
listen it doesn't matter what i believe
i live i live by reality so this is this
is
you're like listen i'm doing five so at
least one may fall through it yeah it's
it's kind of like job applications right
fire them out do you make one job
application and get all hyped up in your
little chair
you make ten job applications you get
three interviews and then maybe you get
one job offer that's fine but the key
thing is the limitation the key
limitation of this is money and time and
so the time restriction is seen here
right three days that's my general rule
because i've got a good job i've got all
this stuff going other [ __ ] you know
stuff like that and the other key
limitation is money so you know
i push it like trading in it you don't
want to invest more than you're willing
to lose i'm not willing to lose more
than 25 pounds on anything
listen you get the first drink i get the
first drink it's like oh you know i'm
being a gentleman if you don't get this
second drink you're not getting anything
else right
this has to alternate this has to
alternate
though i won't even leave i'll just be
like you get in the next round and if
she doesn't i'll be like this [ __ ] i
won't even keep it for four weeks if i
struggle with i'll probably be two weeks
right um so yeah that's that's the main
amount
any any other any other questions class
can i ask a question no what what type
of women do you attract with this what
type of women do you manage to trap in
this cycle um actually
i wouldn't say trap i think they come
with their own accord but
generally my my main demographics are
early 20s university student highly
intelligent intelligence is my key
factor i i can't do dumb girls so in
other words what are they wrong women
with two kids
dumb women are too chaotic for me and
it's just it doesn't fit my lifestyle
right you don't do any dumb hoes up in
here so they all got to kind of know you
know what kind of this guy is that kind
of thing
early 20s and their university graduates
they've gone to good unions and they
just want to mess around and she knows
what she wants i don't have time to
waste so if you if you're kind of just
figuring out you can do that on someone
else's time i've got stuff to do the
other demographic is mid-thirties and
they've kind of been around maybe have
some [ __ ] relationships they you know
almost got married whatever now they're
just chilling these probably they're
easier to maintain as well because you
know they're 30 they don't have to
manage themselves young girls want a lot
of your time and attention the older
women are my favorite because at this
this current time they're just as
attractive as 22 years but they're more
like independent they can manage
themselves less stressful they'll even
take you out did i have kids thanks um
no i don't do anyone oh yeah just one
that's whack yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
second night yeah
so yeah generally is those two
occasionally i will trap a mid-20s girl
trap in her peak
but obviously it's because you know i
know it's not what's best for her and i
i avoid doing that i like i like to mess
with women who
uh we can have fun and it doesn't have
any judgement on a long-term
relationship
i treat every woman like that's
someone's potential wife in it so i
wouldn't do anything with them that like
would make any other guy i have a good
reputation but that's cause i work very
hard but you know this creates trauma
right i'm just going to say like the
younger ones that it does create trauma
you know it's like a cycle of
psychological issues being a modern
woman creates trauma you already have
trauma that's why you like this stage no
but relationship trauma when it starts
in the get-go a woman gets hurt by a man
a man gets hurt by a woman next you know
everyone's just out here just trying to
be savage mode okay like the worst thing
about that let's think about that okay
yeah i'll think about it and here's
here's my output right no one hurt you i
ghosted you no one did [ __ ] you see yeah
i fell in love that's her business b
that was you you you charmed her come on
because i'm a champion exactly we gotta
take some credit for that though yeah
but let's take some credit your feelings
belong to you i can't affect how you
yeah just because i'm awesome
she didn't know you're a gentleman and
she didn't know you're a gender just
because i'm awesome i can now take
advantage
i'm just a good person like you can fall
in love you can do whatever you want
yeah
you've got four week cycles right that's
that's how it is have you been in love
um
also are you single
no
i don't think i've ever been in love i i
have but love love is a strange thing to
me love is kind of like um
placing too much emphasis and importance
on someone outside of yourself to the
point where it affects your general
emotional stability
right so you kind of hype someone open
your i think it's kind of a form of
narcissism narcissism for me like why
why would i think so highly of someone
that i like that they kind of occupy my
mind and i kind of create all this
grandeur about you you're a human with
two legs and two arms that's how i'm
always going to see you
you know
we were created to feel things you know
and love like there's a reason why
people say that feeling and have that
word to describe love right so we're
meant to feel that so if you're saying
that
you don't want to feel that for whatever
purpose that i'm not gonna lie
no i just say i don't wanna feel it yeah
but i don't think it you're telling me
it's narcissistic and basically that if
you feel it like it's gonna overtake you
completely when actually if you ain't
been in it then
how do you know how it actually feels
that's basically what i mean that's
better [ __ ] to a man like me
and care it's time it's discipline love
is not something i throw around it's not
something i see someone somewhere and
say oh i like her for regions like yeah
but i know why i like you you've got a
nice sauce you're cool you're kind of
polite that's why i like you but love is
different there's different levels to
love there's being in that love there's
loving someone like if you love someone
care about someone because you know
they've got your back they're loyal
that's a different type of love that
right there that's just i'm i fancy you
i like you no that's more what you're
talking about for me is more respect and
duty yeah but there's different
definitions then that's what we're
talking about i think when people talk
about love you talk about a state of
like emotional hysteria based on some
perceived you know perceived ideals
about someone you barely know i have a
question i have a question so
hey guys so so when you when you're
looking for wifey are you gonna use this
system and just get rid of the ghosts
we'll be the same system
that's why you wouldn't fall for this
system no she absolutely would because
i'm awesome bro like yeah yeah remember
he's charming
okay wait let him answer the question
i mean i'd have to see someone i think
is wifey so i guess at the moment it's
kind of like
if we get through these stages and i
think you're cool and you show enough
qualities loyalty
um you're intelligent you know you've
got all my long-term qualities then yeah
and that almost happened once
yeah cambridge goal um super intelligent
but she was a feminist i had to dump her
but
it was a four week run you know
she went to spain she was like kind of
into some dude there and i said be free
so
i'm not gonna sit here and try and like
worry about who you are let me ask you a
question why are you running the same
process on a girl that you're right
could you not tell that like like a
little bit earlier on that actually this
one could be a good girl i make no
assumptions in these hosts
she could be a professional girl she
could look polite she could do anything
hoes have so many strategies women's
strategies are way more sophisticated
yeah but mentally resources
no i just understand you guys
yeah vice versa
i don't think you understand i think
you'd fall for this
um so yeah i think i think it's
generally just what it is because it's
based on my experiences and the reality
if you give someone too much attention
and too consistent early on you look bad
it's true if you if you're too kind of
easy to understand um you look bad they
get bored it's not interesting
if you cannot flip between the alpha and
the beta if you're too dominant and you
show no signs of weakness actually yeah
i've got a question
what is what is what is flipping into
the beta in that point to in your eyes
just pretending you need this woman like
you know like she has um just pretending
that like you're looking for some kind
of emotional connection because most
women look for validation attention
constantly it's like it's like they
prefer to food sometimes right so
correction all [ __ ] women look for
attention and validation
dominant animal you know i am right i
won't i don't actually need someone like
that i've got a good job i've got good
friends i don't need i don't go to clubs
and think oh wow this girl's got a nice
house i need her i'm going to text her
all night until she no i don't think
that that's to make her think that
wouldn't you say that i i got what
you're saying but wouldn't you say like
if you've got a girl and she knows other
girls that have been with you or that
she she knows other girls with the guy
right so she almost feels that the
attention that he gives she almost might
have to earn it because he's spreading
it with other people
no that's just the recipe for trouble
because what you're going to do is
you're going to develop a bad reputation
women will create drama and i have the
job is too good for that i can't i can't
wake up stressing is that what is in the
salsa in the salsa world and there's
also the dance world and everything but
in the south award you just learn
quicker because you know you see
everything in a much shorter time frame
the girls come in they go for the same
guys you know he's a sexy salsa guy you
text everyone saying oh do you want to
come meet me at this bar and actually
he's invited you to his class because
he's a teacher
you're going to sit there be impressed
by the attention he's getting eventually
she'll shag this guy because i'm not
going to hustle for you because i'm
probably in the class or just chilling
in the social or something
after that you know you're going to he's
a good looking guy right he's probably
got a decent job he's a good dancer
everything's great you're gonna want to
kind of extend that sexual thing he's
not gonna do that because he shaggers
everyone then you're gonna come to me
right now you want something deeper
because anyone could [ __ ] you now you
realize i was the man the whole time and
obviously you kind of passed my shelf
shelf kind of life by then so
but that's different though so if you
met a woman like you're seeing her in a
second like a specific circumstance do i
mean like i get why you look at her that
way 100 because you watch to do that but
for example if you met a woman
completely random at a coffee shop
random place like
you can't then judge her off of that
like one
place because you don't know her that
was your first meeting she could have
been very polite very well educated very
well job very attractive
where do you sit then
i would still run this exact process in
fact those women are the most the most
vulnerable to this because universities
are basically like left-wing grooming
but don't you think the other women are
more vulnerable because those are the
ones that are emotionally unstable
because they just whip with a man and
realize they don't get vulnerable like
like we stop it
like we act like like women or children
like you're a grown adult you're not
vulnerable i love how like because i
figured out the game i'm an animal like
you know what this this took years of
having your time wasted and being
disrespected and over investing like
until you figure out why this happens
i just i just refuse to believe women
are are super vulnerable and don't know
what they're doing like you know what
you're come on
no obviously people know people are not
dumb but i say that there's people that
live in reality and a dream world and
people don't like facing their reality
so they act dumb and act naive it's only
people that actually know themselves
actually like yeah i know what i'm doing
but most of the time people pretend like
they don't and they try to make
themselves believe that
and that's my point of being vulnerable
like you're you're vulnerable but
obviously you know what you're doing
yeah but that's my meaning when i'm
speaking yeah i understand but i think i
think he's saying like he he'll find his
wife through this system too he just
won't ghost her he'll take out stuff for
you take her out like at this point you
have you have so many opportunities to
show me that you're you're kind of
something better than i would have
imagined
by date three has she had to have given
it up
um yeah yeah i'm not saying that to be
honest to be honest i i don't do more
than like
two days like if one day is my max but
if like
there's a good reason right and after
the date she's like you know i can't
today because you know i'm on my reds or
you know i just don't do it on the first
date all right fine you get a second
date second date nothing then it's like
all right now you have to take me out or
you know there has to be sign because
guys realize that this is all my time
and energy like yeah i understand that
some females watching this may have
convinced themselves that they're
actually victims of this but i've
actually spent my time with energy
without any real return for the past 99
of this process so actually you're kind
of winning the only the only way you're
not winning is that you actually like me
because i'm dope so that's where you're
losing is that you're going to feel you
lost someone valuable because you did
lose someone so when i asked you earlier
that by like at the end of it she needs
to have given you six and you said
you're not too sure
by date three if she hasn't given it up
so then you are saying you should be
seeing six at least no i don't say
should these are like
kind of words is it are they verbs or
something shirts conditional verbs that
just don't exist in my world right so in
other words do you expect sex at the end
of it or you [ __ ] off of course i expect
such a denim do you see this [ __ ] guy
do you think i'm doing this without
expecting a wig all right so you should
you should and you expect i'll just
synonymous here
no there's no [ __ ] is about what someone
else should do i can't tell her what she
should do
i i can only invest my time and energy
with a certain intention yeah and if
that doesn't work out then i simply
i have a question what if what if she
says three months
oh [ __ ] up someone did that someone did
that right
yeah someone did that so there was one
girl that said like three months so she
was like um a dancer she was really cute
we went on like two dates so i was like
damn i'm really doing the most for you
but make this worth it um and basically
the end you're going for like i think
no it was third base or home run or
whatever and she said she made some kind
of excuse she was like oh i take my time
to get to know people this that and so i
never spoke to her again and she turned
up like a month ago and was like trying
to get my number talk to me see these
girls just don't know
what they have and
a lot of women their strategy is i'm not
going to filter for men i'm just going
to let everyone in and see you give me
the most time and attention yes i'll
double down on it and i'll take it a
step further and say that women what
they say they want and what they
actually want in real life are too
complicated do you listen to women of
course i don't [ __ ] listen to him
that's the whole point listen to women
out here but do you think this was
developed by women all women even my
most rational female friends will say
stuff like i want a guy who's nice who's
honest she forgets that she's also
telling me why she doesn't like the nice
honest guys on our other conversations
see
a conversation with women is just an
exercise of cerebral stimulation
you're trying to like you know touch on
as many things as possible make her feel
excited trying to touch certain buttons
yeah but there's no point there's not an
end men we talk with a point in it
there's like an actual subject and an
end goal women talk in an explorative
way it's like improvisation in jazz
right if you understand that you
understand women like when they say they
want a guy who's chat and he's got this
they just want a guy who can kind of
stimulate them in that way without
making them feel like they need to put
something on the table you still do
but i'm just not going to make you feel
like that you should know that because i
expect you to be smart and that's what
we call getting attention and validation
yeah well if you're not smart i just
stop in it and trust me they'll notice
when you're stopping it because they're
probably getting hit on by bums probably
giving their time and attention to guys
that are way less than you because those
are people who win it's not it's not
guys like me
who get the most it's guys who just try
the hardest unemployed guys get the most
asked out of anyone i promise you that
there's no love
there's no look some of you guys in the
comments were like oh you know you have
to be six foot shut up you loser
the guys who are getting the most ass in
london are five foot two spanish guys
with pink hair
i
[ __ ] promise you though there is no
like oh you have to look like brad pitt
no no no no
i can show you some dudes out there but
they're texting everyone they're doing
the most things
together we can be a team he says that
to everyone and they all believe it
because they're 22.
it's a numbers game
going numbers but this is like my level
stuff so you got to be kind of like
reclusive you got to pick people you
want to engage with because i think to
me sex is like a mutually she's a value
i'm of value so in my relationships um i
don't i don't have relationships but in
my roster there's like um there's like
this mutual respect so you could think
of me as a pimp but i'm not really a
pimp because i'm not really pulling
anything over anyone's eyes they know
what's up
and i expect them to be clever and it's
quite fair and if anything like you
could say you're very considerate
because you only go for the girls in
their early 20s and they're mid they're
how nice are you i'm too kind i i could
do i could do a lot of damage out here i
promise you that
i see some girls come in and i'm like
i know exactly what to say to this girl
but you know what i'm gonna get jose
over there i'm gonna let him do the
process because i'm gonna i don't wanna
wanna ship either so what's the point
you know how hide your wives
[Laughter]
you've gotta have ethics guys you've
gotta have ethics that's that's what
separates us from animals you are the
man of the people thank you thank you so
any anyone any other questions from them
no you get an ace off for that
she has a blessing did you meet her mike
oh okay
i had a question
you gotta talk and you gotta talk in
your mind i need to remember it now i
feel like cat has a lot to say was it
was that so much was there something
about me
give us something no you want some sauce
me attracting damaged women no not
thinking about that but you are like you
know exposing yourself right now yeah
nothing about that i'm still gonna win
it's fine
i believe how long have you been doing
this
um well this is just like it's an
evolving framework
um
because to be honest with you like every
woman is kind of different they're like
different kind of narcissists some of
them take pride in their bodies some of
them take bias and how much they can get
out man some of them take pride in
all sorts of things so you gotta there's
no kind of shortcut to like taking
people as they are and trying to
understand where you fit uh but this
first stage never never do you sometimes
look at psychology i i i well
look at psychology like look into it do
some research so then you're fully
equipped for this yeah yeah 100 you know
what this is that first stage number one
that is psychology backstage completely
yeah he's a real tactic he is studying
he is studying right now it's just it's
just like being being conscious in it
and understand i've what i started out
with was just talking to women
generically hey you know you're pretty
cute let's do this let's do that
um and i noticed that when i was way too
direct and honest people you know didn't
reciprocate but when i ignored people
once in a while they thought that meant
i had greater value so that's what i did
right it happened actually because i
have a good job so as my time gets taken
up i don't have the time and that that
kind of fit in well it worked and every
time i gave someone too much attention
the result showed me that actually this
stage is really [ __ ] important you
cannot be constantly available because
what's she gonna think right you met
this guy he's attracted to me and he's
giving me all this attention for free
why would i spend more time engaging
with this person
gash lighting right women hate certainty
if you say to someone i love you you're
great we should get married you're great
that's boring in it what you say is
you're kind of cute
you can kind of see something working
out
but i see a flame in you or some [ __ ]
like that that doesn't mean anything
right and friends
eventually
she will kind of piece that step
together by herself but i can't tell you
what to think i can just like show you
possibilities
but
make make kind of no mistakes i'm not
kind of
manipulating anyone here women are
manipulating themselves listen i'm just
saying i'm just saying i say very little
in this stage she doesn't know who i am
she doesn't know where i'm from she
doesn't know my childhood traumas or
anything like that because i have no
traumas yeah they call it the push pull
theory oh yeah that's true i've heard of
yeah there's there's no push pulling
though because this is a framework for a
higher value person so
the people that are in this framework
are extremely dispensable right but that
fighter to alpha that is technically
push and pull because yeah because
you're pushing in the beta stage you're
giving more validation and attention
than required and then you pull it away
it confuses the [ __ ] out of them you
then give them that mystery and that's
when they worry about you the beta is
not it's actually a pool because modern
women are feminists so the narcissist so
they tend to think that like let's bear
in mind you're pretending beta
yeah i mean i give them what they
clearly want in it you so so you're
dating me you think this guy is awesome
he's got everything what do i have to
offer um just sex really but i have to
convince you that there's something else
that you're really interesting and
fascinating i can't go like more than a
day without speaking to you so you know
i kind of have these conversations
um and
if you stimulate someone in the right
way they will project how they want to
feel onto you you just you just got to
keep on saying general things yeah see i
wouldn't class that as bait i think i
just i'll just class it is giving them
the attention and validation letting
them think that they've got you where
they want you and then you remove it you
pull it and that's when you leave them
thinking that's a bit his whole life
that's what baiters do questions that's
hence why i say you act better because
you're intentionally doing that it's
strategic and then you pull it away this
is basic pick up dating coach
i'm not saying i'm not acting but to me
this is this is all a professional this
is just a professional kind of a process
for me are you holding are you are you
learning about men yeah i'm learning
that is that everything
i've blocked a guy i was right that's
what i'm learning you're going to be
single
i don't mind
i love being single
that's not rude it's not a bad thing
i love it she's got infinite votes okay
good yeah it's not good i don't think
there are many men that could match up
to you just because okay absolutely
amazing you are generally
from what you've said you'll be better
off marrying yourself because that would
be an awesome i'm seeing this framework
in real time right now
you are so insightful in the way you
value yourself i respect that i respect
your boundaries um text me i might
ignore you in other words
there we go
and i
i think jess had a question um it's not
a question you guys said something about
um
you can't make women
think what they want to think and i
would say that the first stage as
interesting as it may be where you don't
say much you say
little as to anything possible and you
just have them speak
essentially i would think that would be
valuable for a woman to do because if
you're saying all this stuff women do
take things you can say no i don't
relationship and women were taken well
he doesn't want a relationship right now
but maybe in the near future he'll want
it
and it's
it's
interesting and like crazy but i can
understand it as well as like the first
stage as you don't say much to help them
understand like this is what i actually
want
this stage is all about kind of tension
it's all about kind of um you're
creating tension and removing tension
yeah yeah but
i'm at this level now where me removing
tension is just like me just not
bothering
it's like when i remove my time and
attention that's that's where like you
know because women women know who the
high level guys are like they spend
enough time around you they know because
i come across as goofy initially because
i do that on purpose because i don't
want any cloud chasers because they're
long
they're long you know you guys are
coming with your shiny belt you're
attracting the most annoying kind of
women for me i want someone who's
intelligent and who generally wants to
mess around and we kind of do this and
women who can maintain themselves and
maintain their own emotional state you
know the kind of sense of being
naturally do this you ever did a mature
woman who was texting you constantly
you ever dated a mature woman who was
like too dominant or too submissive then
actually do that because they have to
function as adults i like adults that's
what i like
you know
um occasionally some young ones but she
has to be very smart this strategy which
is a strategy it's just it's who i am so
yeah though you may have come to this
strategy yourself this strategy is
actually just a standard pickup strategy
it's just common sense
if you're not doing this
and the key thing is guys the women in
this stage are extremely dispensable and
i'll tell you why women think you are
extremely dispensable if you meet
someone even vaguely attractive she's
got tons of guys talking to her all the
time
if you're the top 10 of guys maybe
you're the top 1 or 0.1 like me right
maybe you go to a club and you can find
a relatively attractive girl and get a
number and you know that's nothing
compared to what the average woman can
get a woman who just like looks like a
foot can go to a club and get a man
so let me ask you a question so she
doesn't that's why she can drop you
quickly all women think you're
dispensable so i don't know why some
guys are putting their heart on the line
like oh she rejected me bro
why are you talking to one person why
would you apply for just one job do you
know what i know someone who gave advice
to his boy who was going on like club he
was going out to clubs and he was just
giving his number out to girls and he
was basically saying that
it's it's basically a poker game what he
does is he puts like money on each
different like
um
like card saying okay this card is going
to get me x amount this card's going to
be xml so he'll give out his number to
about 20 girls he knows the odds are
10 of them were probably ugly
because he was probably too drunk then
the other 10
two of them
hoes probably
the other two
probably have kids and then the one
after that may be a good one yeah that
guy sounds wack firstly it sounds kind
of feminine giving out your number
people calling me without my say so
absolutely not but i'm saying he gave
that example i mean where he's saying
it's a games like what you're saying is
why you go for it
but he's saying the same thing you're
saying that you don't know which one out
of the bunch is going to be the good one
which is why you're playing oh it's why
you're not going to put all your cards
on one table well there's a lot there's
a lot of filtering that goes these the
women that go through this process is
maybe
one or two a month yeah but this is just
the contact deals
this is not going through the process
remember that oh getting the contact
that's what i'm saying maybe one or two
a month at most one or two i'm extremely
picky you can't just have anyone hitting
you up or now i'm kind of doing this
thing while i just add cute people on
instagram because i wanna i want more
clout but generally yeah yeah
generally right you just kind of you
know
i'm very selective you've got to be
educated you've got to be intelligent
you've got to be respectful like the
worst thing you can do for me is to
disrespect my time women who come on a
date with me and just expect another day
and just expect to like not not no sex
and just expect me but don't you know
the type of woman you're bringing on
like dates with you though that you
should expect that they're expecting
your they're respecting you and you're
respected but
i can't i can't read people's souls
right someone may come across great you
could have great conversation she could
be educated she could end up being a
donkey you know women people flip i know
a lot of women a lot of older feminists
do this i'm at this age now where like
feminists will try and pretend they're
not feminists now like when that when
they when they're in that danger zone at
28 it's like
oh i was like oh you know you you think
about you know this kind of what do you
think about this gender stuff you know
she's like oh you know
feminism for everyone no it's not i know
you're bitching about dudes
i know exactly what kind of girl you are
but now she's kind of low balling oh you
know
i hate lassandry too no she doesn't this
girl had a group chat on uni i can see
it
when people talk like that there's like
a it's like that's a raven it's like a
vision of like yeah
you know what's happened
she tried it with everyone else and she
slowly started to understand that that
kind of filters her out because when
people say that i feel to you out like
unless you're extremely hot i don't
think there's anyone that's been so
good-looking now because that's just
feminists want a [ __ ] about you in it
that is their goal ask a friend feminist
about their ex and they will always say
negative things that means it's them
they suck
when a feminist loses a boyfriend she
wants to look at like you know was he
abusive was he sexually assaulting is
their natural thing so why would i put
myself in that why would you hire
someone who only [ __ ] about their
past employers no 100 but the other day
not all women are like that we have to
like look at that side as well there's
someone that ain't like that
like
they're not gonna sit there and just
preach feminism and talk [ __ ] about
their ex and just that degrade men like
some women might be all right like i
think i think the issue is that like
most women have been impacted by
feminism because we're all born after a
certain era so like mo the average age
of first marriage in the uk is 31
what what percent of 31 year olds
haven't been ran through no of course
yeah
and what what percent of 31 year olds
are actually wives what percent have a
cookbook
yeah and so like the point is that even
if not all women are like that
yeah they kind of are we kind of are
yeah
yeah and it's like i think it's kind of
something we do as women it's like we're
like oh no not like not all women we're
special are we
you guys don't understand that like this
isn't the thing there's some women that
ain't like that i know you're looking at
the majority but then and as well when
guys are um practicing things like this
it gives us ammo and things too you have
no ammo you're single what do you mean
you've got no ammo you're single he's
single what ammo do you have no i mean
like what you're saying that women [ __ ]
about guys
yeah because when men are practicing
things like this we have things to [ __ ]
about when men act like ignore gas like
yeah oh sorry when men do things like
ignore gaslight and expect so much after
one 25 pound drink like you're giving us
he's the one that said it he said that
he'll pay for a drink for 25 years my
budget is tight you know yeah so when
when when you're treating women like
that like you're giving us things but
you're actually like you're acting like
women are children you make decisions
yes and it's like and it's like i i've
every relationship i've been in it's
it's on me because i made that choice
but you aren't when you're when you're
telling him oh but this is why women
have stuff to talk about no no let me
let me finish it's like when you say
that women have stuff to talk about it's
like you're putting it on the men no
it's on you it's it's your ability to
pick i agree
and that's why right so
with me
he would get blocked in like three days
120 million we can go through my phone
now and i will show you but you're
single
i i yeah i block people by choice
because i do have standards
and i must be quoted and only only some
people actually appreciate that and
understand that but the people that do
we get along and well they're not here
because you're single okay you're saying
it like it's
gone go ahead go sorry but my point is
that
women can say bad things about men and
they do say bad things about men i
personally if i'm in all sincerity i
don't necessarily subscribe to men are
trash because i don't believe in
negative reinforcement
but
when guys are doing things like this
how can you
say oh yeah men are amazing but he's
he's only doing what women respond to he
wasn't human women no no that's why i
know listen what type of women this is
this is like a shame this is like a
shaming tactic that women do it's like
when guys make a general observation
about women which they've spent way more
time studying on how to get laid than
you ever have and they say women are
generally like this they're like well
it's the women you hang around not all
women and it's like okay how
narcissistic are you to think that like
say it was the woman you talking about
i'm saying this is in general what women
say i didn't say you specifically said
that and i said like that right there
it's a shaming tactic because you're
saying oh it's only the women you pick
but it's like no there's whole channels
based on this this is what pickup the
whole pickup community is basically this
is literally just common sense i just i
wanted to ask like
so you would use that to get your wife
i'm not using that this is like
i am this like there's no using this is
what he's used to based on
he said he said no he said he'd get rid
of step step number four
this is how modern relationships are
nowadays people sleep their way into
relationships
when was the last time a guy asked any
girl to be
like be my girlfriend like nowadays guys
just assume or girls just assume no no
one actually
i've i've there's very few women i know
that actually put that in place i am one
100 i'm not your girl until you ask me
one but there's a lot of women i know of
or situations
that women just get into it so
100 that's why i said society
men will know a wife when they see one
and they'll see like if a woman deserves
to be caught in because she's not out
there
well and the thing is you can say like
raise your standards or whatever but if
you're a used car you can't demand bmw
prices or you can but when no there's no
buyers you can't be shocked yeah but
women aren't cars and there's that's not
the point the point it's an analogy it's
an analogy it's an analogy but i can't
remember
it's are you are you a virgin no okay so
if you're not a virgin you're a used car
you know
for free in life no one does anything
for free yeah there's only a certain
amount of time that someone would do
something at the kindness of the heart
now in a relationship both partners have
to come with something
have to that whatever that is for you
specifically
as a person of value 100
but you have to both come with something
and at the end of the day whatever that
is for you as a person that's fine
but society nowadays sex is something
that is giving up way too easy what is
[ __ ] value on a woman how many girls
are losing the virginity at such a young
age like
that's always happen but that's always
happening people act like people stop
people having sex
yeah but the difference is just getting
married yeah but back in the day people
are getting married to those 16 years
old well yeah they'll have kids a lot
quicker yeah
now alex you can you can take that thank
you thank you everyone like roundup
holding a quick round of applause round
of applause that was that was a great
presentation
that was actually good
that's a different day that's a
different shape my guy used to do stand
up immediately
no the back was me
that was me
do you know
there's just one thing though because
you know how you said men spend a lot of
time studying women yeah and learning
how to get laid yeah and then you stated
that women have sex at a very young age
now it's really crazy because men and
women are completely different and women
aren't necessarily looking for sex the
way men are looking for sex
but
men are
from
early men are pursuing women and in
pursuit of sex before women even know
the value of sex
before they even understand that it's
it's something that they shouldn't
necessarily just give away so in other
words men are already on so in other
words what you're saying is from young
men are driven for sex yeah well that's
what we're hardwired for yeah i know
yeah i'm not grateful but so so what
i'm saying i just don't care what you're
women are unfair advantage in that sense
and unfair and why advantage because
we're younger and we're not focused on
those things that men are familiar with
that so we can't defend ourselves what
do you mean defend yourself like if you
make a choice i mean
even if you're underage you know what
you're doing no but if your choice is
ill-informed
how is it ill-informed because you don't
understand no no you understand
you understand
16.
okay okay okay i wasn't stop over
talking me sorry honey i
i've been 16 and you know what you're
doing
and so it's like it's you just want an
excuse to get bailed out oh i was too
young i didn't understand bad decisions
i haven't made any bad decisions okay
then the women you're talking about so
if you make a bad decision there's a
consequence you can't go to men and say
oh but i was young like it's always just
an excuse from women what there needs to
be actually the only thing i'm talking
about is
one people should never ever think that
anybody's value is altered because of
anything because all right can we just
start the therapy session
okay
okay there's a difference between
personal value and your sexual market
value so it's your value in the
marketplace
and it goes down if you've slept with
the whole football team i'm sorry i do
have a question
do you do you desire to be married
um i'm not really i'm not bothered if i
find somebody worthy and somebody
basically
basically in my life there's only two
options i'm either going to stay happily
single or happily married there's no in
between i'm not doing any
unhappy or divorced or anything like
that okay so my second choice my second
question for you
if you had
when did you ever have like an idea of
when you wanted to be
with that person for the rest of your
life when you were younger
well in my 20s i was with somebody for
like five six years okay yeah and then
she must do what
he
oh she
i don't know
but um what yeah so after after being in
that because me i've been in
relationships from 16 to 20 i was with
someone okay then from 21
to
i'll say 28 on and off
okay i was with somebody so and my plans
changed
within those situations okay so my final
question for you is if you had
essentially a blueprint and say
this is your plan you want to be with
this person
this time this age you can achieve it if
you have xyz
and one of them is having
a less body count or not having as many
sexual partners as
sally down the street would you
do that to obtain the goal that you want
um yeah probably
okay so that's essentially that's
essentially what it is in men's eyes if
you have if you want to be as a value
to be able to
achieve the goal that you want in the
end
you can't have
you can't be ran through essentially and
that's something that they value it's
it's weird i'm i'm telling you it's fine
i used to i used to think that like why
do they need to value that blah blah but
it's just something that i can i can
fully understand and appreciate that men
want to value that and that's really
good for them and i can understand why
they value it as well
i can completely understand why they
value it but
i'm saying that
no matter what you've been through what
decisions you made it doesn't mean that
you have to be treated less than anyone
else and
to be honest in
my delusional world
there are women who
have been actually i wouldn't i don't
even know if they've been around food to
be honest but there are women who i know
have probably dated a lot of men
and they're treated a lot better than
even me that i'm still trying to learn
from them i think i think arguably
they're quoted well well arguably
because they understand men yeah and
they understand and they understand they
take time and they've taken time to
learn the perspective of a man about
what he likes what draws him in so you
saying like oh i don't need to
understand men right that's why you're
you're not seeing a correlation between
the value of how a woman might have been
promiscuous yet she's getting men to
treat her that way that's because she
understands
understands the perspective of men so if
you want the same results that they do
because i get it because you're thinking
oh i've not been that way yet she's
getting the thing that i want she's
getting that like she's getting the
marriage she's getting the guy treating
her how you know how i want to be
treated
but i think what that is showcasing is
that if you want a man to be investing
in you in the ways that you value you
need to understand what he wants you
need to incorporate those things into
your being when you're with him
otherwise you're never going to get that
result
i would also add to that that it seems
like you've developed like a coping
mechanism where yeah you pretend you
have all these high standards and you
take a lot of you seem to take a lot of
pride in like oh i'll block this guy or
i'm i'm good at my own mainly that's we
don't need them and it seems to be that
you're compensated for something that
maybe
you've had unsuccessful courting periods
in the past or maybe you thought some
kind of way about yourself but generally
guys women who are healthy and who kind
of um you know are just generally
emotionally and physically healthy
aren't that long like a normal woman
enjoys sex she enjoys your company it's
not going to take her three months to be
like maybe damaged women are because
they want you to compensate for the
damage they've taken on
i would say that's about they want you
to essentially take not take
responsibility but they're punishing you
for their past mistakes it's essentially
what's happening oh they're looking for
you to fix what's been broken but that's
yeah because the relationships are just
the fact by fact it's just compromising
that whole kind of infrastructure i gave
you is compromising between my time and
the amount of energy and effort i'm
willing to put in for what i'm going to
get out but
that that that kind of structure doesn't
kind of take into account all the things
that i bring to table being a good
dancer knowing great spots knowing how
to entertain someone being patient
honest kind
especially honest i never lie to people
that doesn't take into account all those
things because you have to compromise
anyone who pretends that they're out
here taking wins and everyone wants them
and they've got six rosters no they're
not the women i mess with
i respect them they're up there for me
like i thought if she asked me to come
and help out now i would i would
literally jump out this chair and go
help her because she adds value and i
add value to her in it yes it has to be
mutual have you always uh has it always
been like that for you or did it come to
a point where you're like
why am i doing x y z for women if
they're just going to essentially treat
me like this why don't i just play the
game along with them or has it always
been like now i'm a
dude follow this for a while um i've
always been treated fairly well i've
never had a long-term relationship but i
think my main thing was the frustration
in the early periods that that like
courting phase where you're investing
all this time you're talking to her
you're trying to keep her attention and
you know
you're trying to show you're this tough
guy and you're showing all these good
traits but you also have to kind of
convince her that you need her and she's
so fascinating and she's a flame and
she's gorgeous and whatever and
you gotta you've gotta kind of alter in
between that was my challenge and then
getting them out on dates but once i get
someone out on a date it's pretty much
done but the women i on my roster are
women that i don't really have to do
that for i just say yeah you're pretty
cool do you wanna do you wanna go to
this like bowling alley thing in
shoreditch yeah cool and i don't mind
because for me i reward women who are
straightforward because that show is
respecting her if she's wasting your
time playing games she doesn't respect
you what she's doing is she's creating
hoops for you to jump through it's an
ego thing i'm smarter than you i know
exactly what you're doing so who are you
feeling who are you feeling the girls i
mess with have to be intelligent because
intelligent women don't need to be
convinced and manipulated they don't do
hints
adults
no she knows what she wants she's
educated she's not dumb she's not out
here i'm in an orange she knows who i am
i don't have to be mr alpha with the
gold belt i come in i'm humble i talk
some [ __ ] i'm a bit goofy but she knows
she understands that anyone who tried to
touch me would probably die in it fact
you're just not stronger you're not
athletic you're not more athletic than
me you don't have better contacts you
don't have a better job you're not
slicker than me but i don't have to show
that to you in it because showing things
attracts people who look at surface
things and they are chaotic the worst
women you can [ __ ] with are the chaotic
ones because they were [ __ ] all over
your life
that's the worst thing you could [ __ ]
do that'll affect your job that will
affect your friendships should be
buzzing up your phone should be talking
[ __ ] about you to other guys
for sex why would you well do you and
you have to work for that as well
can i ask you something you said yeah
yeah so
one i i want to ask you two things one
right so first you just said that like
you don't deal with women that play
games
but wasn't that thing on your board just
like literally your game plan
it's the structure and how to approach
them and it's not a game it's a strategy
i would consider it a game that's why i
would block him because i hate games
yeah but i won't chat to you anywhere so
you need to stop saying that two the
women on your roster
i know right
i'm wondering who's triggered here the
woman on your roster
me
talking about how you're going to block
me
i'm not triggered there's been so many
things since you don't think clips i'm
going to have to trigger
there's so many things here that could
have triggered me but out there in
windsor it's cold
you were telling me before you got to
the show you were triggered
you know the mirrors come up and things
start floating
you know
i can sleep with anyone else i'm so used
to i'm so used to insecure people taking
shots so it's all good it's not a shock
anyway the second thing i wanted to ask
is any of those women on your roster are
any of them like women that you would
consider like serious or
marriage
potential and if not why are they still
there what are you what do you date for
um
i guess i would consider some some of
them
i have no intentions of settling down
right now so
that that like
that's already
built in
um
but what i date for is just to have
great seductive encounters with people i
think you can have a lady or woman who
behaves properly and is intelligent and
who generally adds value just by being
feminine and and pleasant and you know
we can hang out and spend some nights
together watching movies and going out
to bowling alleys and doing all the
things you do for fun we can do it in
respectful way you know she can she'll
pay for some i'll pay for some sometimes
i want to treat her for a birthday i
took one girl out paid paid for like you
know five stars whatever kind of dinner
and that's fine once in a while 25
pounds
she's been with me for a while
doesn't
he leaves the girls in their mid-20s
alone right yeah
oh my gosh that's what i'm like
does too
oh
you said a minute ago that this strategy
that you classed as a game that you said
is the reason why you don't go near men
right guys you played you said guys you
guys who play this game you don't go on
it the truth of the matter is i may not
be talking about you specifically but
generally right
you women are more susceptible to that
strategy and you don't even know
probably probably
yeah probably i i yeah probably but i
kind of realized that that whole ignore
thing for attention and stuff like that
and it really puts me off yeah
can i can i also just have your time
do you know the amount of the amount of
women i know who just said what you said
who completely fall victim to it hence
why i said earlier what you say you want
what you respond to in real life two
completely different things i can say
that as a fact i've experienced that
well um
if this show is popular enough dudes i
have blocks
and they will confirm that
it's fine probably not the same
thank you alex for the lovely
presentation
i think that's the most
the most the guest has ever brought to a
show
you know um okay so
we there's gonna be a lot so i'm just if
anyone has any issues with what's said
hold it till the end hold it till the
end because there's a lot it's not
coming from me okay jonathan farley i
would like to quote previous guests like
alicia or the zimbabwe girl since you
didn't reply to my 44 page letter i
assume you're not interested can paying
members pass letters along to them
you sent someone a 44-page letter from
my show
okay
almighty tien i honestly think myrtle uh
myrtle you urkel is trolling there's no
way she should be this dumb unless she's
mentally slow big breezy girl in the
blue isn't as lame as her free friends
matt butcher blue turtleneck is creating
her new identity on the fly being very
defensive for some reason
andrean21 never made a bad decision
delusional joshua i can't ever imagine
the girl in the blue is raising anyone's
children with her outlook
almighty tien myrtle yerkel is a
complete clown lawrence bullock only
traditional women that are virtuous
deserve to be courted
christian s camilla she thinks she's
special eddie e curly hair in the middle
you are fine from the front and the back
drop your socials
yeah you wanna you wanna drop your ig no
no you shouldn't have
jbf m101
the one in the blue is a clear repeat
victim of step three um
yo yo fight the algorithm fight the
matrix you are pearly neo and sarah
morphis and jess keep it going guys mt
modern women are feminists there isn't
isn't a feminine one among them hot ice
most of you left out that courtship has
always been for the purpose of exploring
the possibility of marriage urban
politics in reality your hoframs became
single mothers despite searching for
some simp to come save them from
themselves p gaz as a man i would rather
be my be on my own than with a 40 year
old with 12 kids no matter how great the
hands of the no matter how great the
years of hands-on experience makes her
in the sack maverick
no amount of logic or pragmatism will
get through to the girl in the blue
because she's a supremacist that's why
men are starting to no longer negotiate
with the terrorists hashtag passport
bros sb gorilla um bless your heart
pearl you really need to start kicking
people off the show no need to be rude
or talking over the host religiously pam
from martin is out of effing control pam
is killing me with the grandma glasses
and multi-jack um cognitive with her
shot down with someone never i don't
can't read that one ali balgoan the girl
in the blue sweater is basically saying
nothing is true everything is permitted
good or bad shout out to the assassins
creed hot ice um d maters d
de mayor's competitive over talking and
controlling ways
are exactly what would make every man
refuse to court her
kane marco the chick in the blue is the
female equivalent of the dude in the
couch with the glasses yesterday
absurdity and lack of understanding at
its finest dragon stellium one zero zero
one lady in the blue uh person a person
earns a relationship they don't deserve
it deserve it as you claim um zero
fallout this is why red flail space this
is why red pill spaces are needed it's
helping the average man wake up to the
raw deal that they've been getting this
is the reason that women hate the
manosphere they're afraid their their
fallback plan will disappear um wendell
coven does the girl in the blue
understand that there are more women on
the planet than men there is not a man
for every women woman explain that logic
numbers guys zero i need more ma
i need more modern masculine bars
visionary james ryan
i read that one earlier um mt what royal
court does what royal court does she
belong to i'm not courting any woman
without a dowry and a royal title
marriage causes marriage causes divorce
marriage and birth weights are falling
men are out hot ice
courtship is not a right that any woman
deserves women can anticipate it but
only after they do the work of building
a female character including submission
and moral purity that men want um jay
larosa we need to hear back from the
young lady in the back i'm tired of the
inept librarian i've been here 30
minutes and i nearly slammed my head
against the wall trying to tune her out
david x why who said the girl from
florida didn't have a uk accent daniel
jamerson vanilla gorilla getter
that means um lauren um lol the blue
blue sweater is 30 and single i wonder
why baba ganoush hard
hard question to the women and the
turtleneck on the couch would she tell
the men who was courting her that she
believes that women are more valuable
yeah you would okay um numbers guys you
know um yesterday was the redhead last
week it was the pink shirt and today
it's the blue the sea is cursed to
dominate the conversation with i feel
like dragon stellium1001 lady in the
blue is just another strong independent
cat lady gus modern women are walking
contradictions the uk economist please
ask what type of men of man based on his
income they think they qualify for or
wizard eight pearl deserves to be
courted young lacks women don't need a
bf for protection men also don't need a
gf for sex women can't build a legacy
without a man neither so men don't need
women either jojo smith blue girl lives
in her own world and admits it would
rather make pearl and jess dreams come
true bunk beds and sister wives
shout out jess shout out pearl
sentience men will automatically believe
if a men will automatically believe if a
host says her body count is zero you
mean the same one you touted as being
able to get him off so quickly smart men
watch for patterns and a hoe will act
and dress like one to the streets they
go
dragon stallion one zero zero one does
the woman not understand that happens
when you have sex with a virgin there is
physical evidence that they are a virgin
big brown
someone please tell blue sweater she is
a three at fast recreational use only
jayla rosa what do you where do you find
the unemployed librarian she makes no
sense speaks complete nonsense and
sounds childless childish she needs to
think through her answers david mavro
no amount of evidence will convince a
person who starts every sentence with i
feel instead of i think sentience if
women are strong and independent why do
304 is like blue sweaters need a man to
buy them things i would guess laziness
and entitlements as for men needing
women men only need women to reproduce
otherwise we are happier without the
shrieking andrei and andrea d girl in
the blue how on earth would you help a
man build a legacy what have you done in
your life that proves you can build
anything all you want is free things
where's your effort sentience women are
wanting to show that they are masculine
do you not need do you not see the
inerrant problem with that statement
hetero men don't want to date or sleep
with another man so as women show more
masculinity you think men will like that
john james we're all dating to have sex
that's the point jc women talk about how
they don't chase men then in the next
sentence complain about how those guys
only want sex you you limit your options
by doing that gus women get mad at facts
if the shoe fits james ryan pearl why
don't you just kick these people off
your show given that the nonverbal tics
i can guarantee they are not listening
won't listen and i'm talking about the
blue sweater v jokes how do we get women
in today's western society to go back to
traditional ways
candace ravenstag it doesn't work every
girl i've courted has abused it they've
been they've berated it as too clingy or
desperate it's a case of saying one
thing while wanting something else girls
lie about what they want
maximus if you want to be courted sex
must be on the table by the second date
third if she's a nine marriage causes
divorce guy in the black speak to
solicitors or divorced men before you
get married you're going to lose 70 of
your money if you get divorced
one it's celcio pearl can you play us
some guitar please
um okay so
someone submitted a question on my
instagram that i thought was actually
pretty good let me pull it up
um also guys make sure you like the
video the number one metric that youtube
uses to push out videos is
through the like button and there's 3
700 of you in here right now
um so we should at least have 2 000
likes half of you need to like the video
come on take two seconds a thumbs up
yeah yeah that's what i'm saying um okay
so
what was it it was something
i do have a can i ask a question yeah
i'm gonna find it yeah for the women
after we had our wonderful presentation
from alex
do you think women
have a sort of lineup like that to get
what they essentially want from men and
that's
either money
time or whatever they value in a man
i think women will always know what
they're doing like i said earlier people
might bat like they're vulnerable but
people are not dumb and if you're a
woman who's realistic with yourself
and you're playing a game you want to
talk about hoes and strippers and girls
in the streets
there's girls out there that know how to
play men but also the men know what
they're doing they they actually enjoy
it so it's a mutual risk like
like everyone's get what they want in
the day but i think women do know
how to play the game
but i think there's women personally in
my circle that don't play the game
but there's women that can play the same
exact game
simple as
obviously it's a bit different from a
man women will use sex to get what they
want from a man
i think women develop much more
sophisticated games very early on quite
naturally so i was a massive physics
teacher for a while and i noticed that
pretty much 15 14 starts as long as even
12 like you know year 7.
these girls are already lying they're
already practicing like triangular
relationships like love triangles
because all girls watch
is romance right the the eternals you
know
they idolize that stuff they practice
for these complex situation and in fact
some and often times they actually want
these situations to happen because they
enjoy these scenarios kind of like every
man wants to be the man every girl wants
to be the guy that you know the girl
that guys fight over inherently and so
women naturally develop much more
sophisticated ways of playing the game
also they have something you want right
sex so
naturally they start learning how to
filter and how to play the game but
because of social media it tinged the
game too much in favor of attention
before i think i think there was other
things in the courting process right she
would she would kind of think more about
like his ability to take care of her xyz
but now because of social media and the
dopamine you get from like having people
look at you and like your stuff and
people think you're great and having
that clout young girls are got kind of
seduced into this like i want to play
this game
women are constantly getting my
attention and validation that they want
there's no need there's no need past
that point to give anything up they're
getting the intention and validation
that men usually don't just give out for
free i want to hear your two's uh
answers to my question
i'm just interested
yeah i feel like i've been talking a lot
so i'm just you know i'm just taking
everything in but i i i agree i think i
think women know how to play the game i
think we know what we want to do
but i think that's a general thing
not every woman knows exactly
what a game is or what they maybe even
want
i just no don't worry i just feel like
i know we're not talking completely
generally but i feel like
opinions here are very much like black
and white i think that's why i've kind
of just been
very in the you know fly on the wall
type thing
um and i also don't like to interrupt
that's kind of why i've just been
sitting here but i think at the end of
the day we all
men and women we all know what we want
at the end of the day so
i think modern women don't know what
they want
i was gonna say regardless in regards to
like
women naturally learning that it
actually a lot of it starts at home and
it's very very common you see this in
studies where the daughters will and the
daughter and the mother start competing
for the father's attention
and it's very common because it's his
little girl that she almost takes
priority because how many times do we
see
like a daughter who has that her father
wrapped around her finger right
especially if he's like very wealthy or
whatever and all this so it actually
starts
a lot of it can start very very young
and it's really common that it starts
young especially when you've got the
father in the home and that's almost how
she learns how to get the male attention
she doesn't you don't even realize that
it's from the parents but it is
so just to play
what about the other ones that didn't
have a dad or vice versa because
sometimes it doesn't always just play on
social media yeah of course i mean but i
mean it starts it can happen at school
as well likes to start at school
it's social media it can be it can't be
such a circumstance women know which
women get the attention the girls go on
their instagram and they see that the
girls the women who have the attention
who are being shared
that's modern day yeah yeah
that's that's that's modern day in terms
of online
but i'm talking like let's say just
classic in the playground or something
like or you're just like at school i i
agree with you because like i would say
um my family has a lot of like high
achievers and because that's kind of how
we would compete for our parents
attention it was like doing good at
sports or doing good at like whatever
yeah so you get validation yeah yeah
so is this one can you hear me
yeah yeah it should be on
yeah i was on yeah yeah so young boys
typically they try to gain
their parents approval through
achievements and accolades yes whereas
girls typically use
the
the manipulation tactic of
i'm i'm basically upset or i'm hurt
which which makes it brings out the
nurturing
so it brings it brings out that side of
men that's protective and makes men want
to protect the daughters which gives
them the attention of what's a
manipulation tactic
but then with nowadays if we look at
society how many men are in
their children life and their daughters
like how many women are in their son's
life like if we look at both there's
a lot of men that are not there women
that are not there for the kids vice
versa they're growing up without a full
family loving them and understanding
what to look for in a man or in a woman
yeah we try which i agree is wrong
however so how do we look for it now
that's what i'm saying like
movies instagram social media which i
believe an episode needs to be done on
by the way yeah i truly believe social
media instagram uh erotic novels
everything else oh on that point as well
for anyone who's not seen it
sex life a documentary on netflix if you
haven't watched it you [ __ ] need to
it's only 10 episodes but that series
projects everything we've gone through
today it's an i think a good an episode
on that would be [ __ ] amazing give
that give that series a go because yeah
men you're going to be pissed
so i have i have a question for the men
what can a modern woman
do for a man to outperform what
traditional women have offered in the
past
[Music]
what can a modern woman so
what can a modern woman do for a man to
outperform the traditional women
that what traditional women have offered
in the past i would say i'll say help
with this career because back back in
the day tradition like the women didn't
have the opportunities in the career
space to open doors or to provide like
even even simple things it's just like
i remember i was dating a girl once we
went and trained to the gym together and
a guy she was like attractive a guy gave
her like like a free foam thing for
training and she just gave it to me and
i was just like she used her perks
to serve my life in some way so i'll
probably say the difference is i forgot
if a woman can help a man in his career
in some way that's something that
traditional women traditionally couldn't
have done because they didn't have
access to that but i would always i
would also say instead of instead of
trying to outdo the traditional women i
would say bring back what traditional
women have their values right so be
beautiful be youthful be pure don't just
be sleeping around with everybody be
feminine be submissive and support your
mind but i think the question is from
the point of view is like you can't undo
you know being through yeah you can't go
back and you once you're older
i think so if you have been ran through
yeah
i think really and at that point all you
can do
is turn turn turn another leaf
stop sleeping around really all you've
got to do is
just take on the exact opposite
behaviors that got you to that stage
start being submissive which outside of
the sex submissiveness and femininity is
lost right hence the hence the
expression toxic masculinity we wouldn't
have that expression if women didn't
feel that they need to be masculine and
they don't like the fact that men are
right so be feminine be submissive stop
sleeping around at that point and start
supporting your man start being start
being the
basically start exhibiting all of the
things the nurturing behavior the
gentleness
everything that would make a woman
a good mother that's what i would say
what do you what do you think alex um
for me so i'm a modern man right so i
get a lot of a lot of the viewers are
people who are very traditional they
really want that you know the old school
ways for me
stuff like body count isn't too big at
all it's more about how you behave like
i like women who are respectful i feel
like modern women are very disrespectful
yeah they naturally don't respect your
time they don't respect your attention
um and they just don't respect men you
know this toxic masculinity thing um and
so for me one key thing is being
respectful being feminine because i
don't care what anyone says feminine
femininity is a currency like there are
some days where you want to curvy you
know
pleasant woman next to you and none of
my boys
you know there's no amount of friends
you can have that would make that like
less gonna make up for it yeah and
finally
um i like women who are dynamic like you
gotta
it's a modern world so the whole idea of
the provider and you know the woman
being submissive doesn't really hold up
because you know jobs jobs you can't
have a lifelong job anymore salaries
kind of can fluctuate there's recessions
and so i'm extremely dynamic i'm a
contractor you know i manage people um
and i may be doing other things and you
know starting business i've got side
hustles and i need a woman who
understands that and who's also dynamic
like you can't be sitting here kind of
like waiting for the next day like i
want someone who's on their grind who
can add to my grand we can talk about
things because now women have the same
access to as mental education so you can
have as good a conversation as i can you
know what i actually agree with that
right i agree with everything you just
said however i believe they're very
surface level i still believe women need
to bring back and start to exhibit
the the essentially the traits the
characteristics the attributes that men
biologically are wired to right so
that's not sufficient i have a question
do you do you think there's going back
for modern women because i
i just once a girl's been damaged to a
certain point like it just seems like
she's kind of like that forever yeah i
wouldn't say i wouldn't say she can undo
the damage but she's essentially got to
make the best out of a bad situation
she's got to try it to some degree but
you can't undo that damage
yeah i mean you can she can she can try
also
also also there's a hundred dollar super
chat so i'm gonna read it real quick
yeah
i guess just so you guys know when you
do 50 to 100 super chats i just read
them like as quick as i see them no need
to quarrel modern women the hard lessons
from men are learning we'll make them
adjust accordingly the regression will
be back to the conservative mean
that's that's happening already yeah the
happiest people i knew in university
were the guys who couldn't be bothered
today i remember because i used to ice
to be an r.a so i used to manage a
thousand students um and it's why i
learned a lot of this stuff because
people talk about the stuff they think
i'm manipulative no i just know women in
it i've actually been out here for like
for like years in it um and one of the
guys he's like i think he's like um an
actuary and his friend
two of the happiest human beings i've
ever met i walked in there
just chilling making lunch for each
other they used to go gym do all this
stuff but i never heard them discuss
when they weren't dating anyone they
didn't give a flying [ __ ] he still
hasn't purchased anything happiest
people the people i know who sleep
around men as well because hypergamy
does make a lot of men unhappy are you
know they're constantly in that drama
phase they're constantly like yeah great
it's not it's not a happy place which is
why everyone should have a roster
spin places
but as in
shallow relationships with multiple
people so you're just running through
them as i said i don't run through
people like like the rush they are
actually valid people i just don't want
to settle down so why would i build a
really intense relationship with one
person but see that's you i think and
there may be obviously a percentage of
men that do that and that's that's fine
but you also have other percentages of
men like if we broke it down to a pie
chart you have the men that out here
just having sex for ego and just to be
validated
you have the men that are doing it
because they don't want a relationship
but they want some company and that's
fine they're not really trying to hurt
anyone out here but they're not trying
to set it down cool then you have the
men that actually want to get married
have like an actual life with a woman
then you have the men that are actually
damaged because they've been they've
been women that are damaged now they
have damage and they don't end up
getting with anyone because they're no
they get the most girls actually the
damage but you know what happens with
them
the 34 year olds the 50 year olds the
six girls that stay single but i have to
keep dating young girls because older
women
she don't want you no actually it's
easier to get older
at that point i think no i'm saying
he'll date younger women because the old
woman at some point an older woman
she'll either settle
or she'll be like i can't be bothered to
put up with this there's two types of
women they'll settle they won't
put up with what put up with someone who
for example is too stubborn doesn't care
about their feelings don't want to give
them attention well that just means
she's shooting out of her league if like
that's the way the guy treats you she
doesn't like you
you're just i'm saying
that toxic place after they've not
transitioned like showing up
if it's high value
do you know different types of women i'm
just talking about different types of
men and i'm saying that's fine because
you're in a different place but i'm
saying if we're looking at percentage of
men in general you have these different
types of men just like how you have
these different types of women like
there's no general for anyone let's be
honest do you know why like those
damaged men do the best in the dating
market yeah because they know how to
play the game because they're good at
flipping between alpha and beta
they're good at being like the tough guy
but they also have deep emotional needs
so they'll try and connect with these
women emotionally they'll flip between
those they're not like you though you're
saying that you don't connect with them
on that level because you understand
your emotional like say boundaries to
keep yourself away from that because you
don't want that but some men they might
be like oh yeah i want this actually
freak out it's the same with women
that's what i'm saying like the pie
chart is there if if a woman's freaking
out in the courting stage you're doing
something wrong you're going wait
because every single woman i date
generally if they're good intelligent
women most women want a long-term
relationship if they're not with you
then you're missing something and you
know you're probably giving way too much
attention and validation you're probably
needy there's something there because
the longer you spend with a woman the
more she's going to like you in it women
are like that when she's committed to
spending time with you she's not
i'm not speaking for america you guys
are crazy i don't know what's going on
over there
10 years behind you guys i think we're
getting there but
i see videos of women being like oh i do
this and i leave i like i sleep with men
and i ghost them it's like what
i mean you've seen some of the vlog the
blog pages here you guys got wild [ __ ]
on those too
i haven't seen
that um
but yeah so they're good at flipping
with that but um but that's the
transition period there's a transitional
period in life
sorry in other words they've got game
yeah but there's the transition bro
because it's kind of pathetic these guys
also i i'm going to sell this once and
for all right this idea that sleeping
with loads of women means you're like a
top guy it doesn't it just means you're
exactly most of the time it means you're
a loser it means you don't you don't
have any goals why do you need an ego
stroke you're not you're not pushing for
anything you have way too much time to
spend you know uh putting like 20 women
in the talking stage and then dealing
with all their games until you fight
they finally sleep with you it normally
means
high value men are selective not just
anyone can walk into my life i agree
exactly usually usually they are making
up pruning security or they're trying to
feed the ego normally they spent too
much time in a long-term relationship in
like their early twenties and then she
left and then they're trying to make up
now they want to date all those others
they're getting a lot of attention now
that's normally what i see the guys who
are sleeping with being promiscuous past
like 25 to like in their 40s they dated
one girl for like seven years when they
were like 18. and then she left and then
they think [ __ ] i could have slept with
all these hotties and now now they just
want to stick with as many as possible
that's why they say that like men with
more sexual partners are like happier in
their relationships yeah can i just say
exactly what you just said so men so
when men
okay the happiest relationships are when
like they're both virgins like that's
number one
but it's like if a man slept with around
i don't remember exactly what it was but
it was roughly like three partners
versus eight or nine partners he's
happily he's happier in his relationship
when he's had eight or nine yeah i i i
tested out i think
men this has just been my experience the
more women i've slept with the more i've
worked out what it is i want what i
don't want it's essentially it's
unintentionally been a screening process
or weeding out the weak type of process
and now it's me and now it's essentially
it left me in a position where i knew
exactly what i wanted what was
completely non-negotiable
and
i would shoot for that i would be very
selective and that's made me very happy
now you have to screen guys like there's
no a lot of guys are frustrated right
now and you know i see it in the
comments because a lot of guys you give
way too much time and attention to women
who have nothing to offer back and they
get frustrated and as a guy who's been
way past that stage i'll tell you most
of these people aren't they don't care
about you they don't like you the
average woman so you've got a screen too
oh yeah a lot of guys looked at that
stage and we're like you know like i
think i just talked to anyone on the
road nah b i have to kind of lack and
respect you first like that's just a
stage and the ignoring bit is when i
have conversations i say things and try
and inquire but if someone doesn't give
me a good enough response if it's not
like if i ask her more than three
questions and she doesn't ask me
anything back i just stop replying right
like i'll just read you know i
i have a super chat real quick it says
people wanting real solutions this is a
conversation about healing seeing
acupuncturist or a tantric yoga expert
so on the damage is not permanent
there's no perfect solution but if you
don't mind it don't matter commit to
what matters okay go ahead kid i have a
question for the fellas do you think
that the more sexual partners a guy
has been with the harder it is for him
to accept one woman for the rest of his
life no
no no
i think well actually i don't want to
generalize here i'm going to say
specifically for my for my position no i
think
getting loads out of my system when i
was younger has allowed me to be far
more selective know what i want and what
i don't want as and now has
made me very specific in who i want to
go for and as
i am now in a happy long-term
relationship as a result and i attribute
a lot of that to essentially the
quote-unquote weeding out process that i
went to i think
so the host can kind of be like
can i ask you a question yeah you you
helped pave the way for the [ __ ]
woman in the future
i think it does make it easier because i
as i develop in my ability to connect
with people yeah as what you said i
start to see
how to understand how to have better
relationships but i mean it depends on
what you mean
i think there's a point of diminishing
returns i agree like when you reach a
certain number and you've slept with
enough people i've slept with posh girls
rich girls celebrities
and it's kind of like i kind of know
what kind of qualities i like yeah um
and
you know i've i've experienced at least
some points where like you've really
connected with people like on a
non-sexual way like
like i actually just like you as a
person i think you're just but you
wouldn't you wouldn't you wouldn't have
anyone on your roster unless you
actually like them as a person anymore
yeah yeah yeah but when a man is ready
to settle down to settle down if i'm not
i'm not
do you think part of it is because i
know maybe it's the the stereotypical of
logical thinking do you think if a man's
ready to build a legacy then he
understands that's the sacrifice he's
willing to make it is a sacrifice giving
up my freedom is a big sacrifice
sacrifice
investing that much emotional energy
time attention to someone is a massive
sacrifice you better be the real deal
you better be there i can't afford to do
that and even legally like men are at
such a disadvantage in the laws today so
that's why earlier when you were talking
about how men gain more from marriage
they get they gain the risk to that you
can leave take half and the kids
leverage your kids against you get more
rights in this country that's a fact
yeah you gotta be you gotta be like lit
you gotta be serious like
um
i mean thinking of it as a sacrifice as
opposed to an investment like
so thinking of it as a sacrifice as
opposed to an investment like it's both
okay cool but that's that's what that's
that's one more of that's what an
investment is though you sacrifice some
funds to invest in something there's
those that's time energy attention i
could be spending elsewhere but i choose
this one person
that that's that's like and now they
have and and now they have the risk so
they're they have the risk that you
could leave and take half you might not
do it and you might assume that like you
might think that you won't but there's a
50 chance
that the marriage ends in divorce
and it's a 70 to 80 chance that the
woman leaves 90 chance if you're college
educated so from a dude's point of view
like that is a huge risk why do you in
your eyes why do you see marriages more
of a benefit for the man than the woman
mainly because
most men
when you get married i think it
makes life more stable you're able to
focus more you're able to
yeah basically just focus more can you
not do that with a relationship without
marriage um
maybe but then i think the fact that the
woman is
more likely to leave
they don't i mean to be honest
you guys are all complaining about how
bad marriage or how it's not good and
how women are like this and how certain
women don't deserve this then just don't
get married
no okay i think i think all this stuff
about it we just talk about the reality
of what comes with marriage today
especially for men right that's what
we're saying but do you find it
interesting how like she did she doesn't
recognize the sacrifice for men i do
that's a lot of women who just don't but
i think i don't get it but i think i
think a big part of that though is
because
i don't think women have the same
appetite for variety that men do
so when so when a man if a man grows
accustomed to having a variety it is a
sacrifice for him i mean because the guy
who doesn't have rights it's not
sacrifice for him like their
relationship is only a bonnet there's
only a bonus i agree with that yes
if a man is married do you think he's
entitled to sex
with his wife yeah yeah of course why
not do you think if she's not giving it
him sex that he can cheat
no i don't think if she's not giving do
you see sex as a duty from the wife
it's a duty for both of them yeah it's
part of like it's part of married life
to have sex with your husband
considering but considering that's
predominantly the woman's value if a man
isn't so for example a man says i
require so i'm providing everything it
can't just be any bloke you're married
he's providing absolutely everything he
says i want sex four times a day you say
no do you believe
if you can't hack that he should be able
to explore that sexual uh desire
elsewhere if you are not satisfied and
when he satisfying you with all of his
resources time and energy and provision
if you as a woman if it doesn't bother
you as a woman that your husband is
going to step out and cheat then call
let him cheat
okay
the thing is you're now giving him every
reason to step out and cheat like i'm
not saying a woman should have sex with
a man but don't you want to have sex
with your man four times a day yeah
listen honestly
like let's be honest he's doing
everything for you he's doing everything
literally you've asked for you would
have wanted
modern women
you show up to they show up to their
jobs when they don't want to but they
won't show up to their husbands when
they don't want to or
this is why i say you want to have your
cake and eat it i think the man at that
stage if he's if he's again he has to be
providing everything he can't just be
bumming around doing [ __ ] all yeah he's
providing everything that's his value to
you right the provision okay naturally
if the value for a man from you is the
is sex and you're not fulfilling that
desire the way you're being fulfilled
uh from your desire
do you believe that he
it's like um and i think marriage looks
different for
everybody
to be honest so i think that's a cop-out
i personally think that's a copy i think
when you say marriage looks different
for everybody in what sense in the sense
that okay i'm thinking about like will
smith and jada they've
re-negotiated and rearranged their
marriage
will smith
will smith when you say they're
renegotiating what you're actually
saying is will smith trying to attempt
to grow up to be honest
who knows what goes on i think that's
how i do relationships
i feel like you guys
it's okay it doesn't matter
i could imagine will smith gives
everything he gives his fame he gives
this time he forgives her for whatever
she does yeah but she doesn't she does
this
but are we going off of what social
media and he worships her she says oh i
i kind of i still loved tupac and i
settled for you and he goes well well
marriage for life you know yeah you know
i think um i think you would love that i
think that's what you and i
don't mind because you don't know me
that very that very man that very man
who
the man you just described will smith
the man who who bends over backwards he
gives you everything and you you have no
respect for him that there is a
picture-perfect example of the man who
would take on a woman at 40 years old
with 12 weeks wait so so were you saying
they were a good example i didn't think
you were yeah i was i was trying to say
that the way that they have basically
defined marriage how they want to define
it right
they can have an they've agreed to have
an open
marriage and
they're
entitled to that that's agreed prior i'm
talking if the relationship the
presumption when you start a
relationship like any or the married
story was like any other marriage in the
western world or relationship in the
western world which is we are together
there's going to be no cheating he
provides everything she doesn't give him
the sex or sexually satisfy him does he
have the right to guarantee
with the presumption in the beginning
that they are monogamous do you know i
think okay in if i was to get because i
can't talk about anybody else but myself
if i was married and my husband wanted
more of me than i could give i would
hope that we had a good enough
relationship for me and him to sit down
and for us to discuss options if that
meant a threesome bringing other women
in then
i would be down for it do you know what
i respect the answer okay i respect that
oh common ground yeah
okay
okay so um i think we're gonna close out
the show um why don't we go around
everyone say your final thoughts and if
anyone has a super chat they want me to
read um send it now while they're giving
final thoughts and i'll read them before
we finish the bigger number you send the
quicker she'll read it thank you yeah so
if you want to think then why don't we
start with jordan and go around
so i would say ultimately
learn to understand what it is men and
women want from a surface level and a
biological
standpoint
understand men and women
um
in regards to the original question
do more women get deserve to be courted
the higher value she is in your eyes
then the more you probably do that but
she's not that high voting and it's not
going to happen that's the truth
um final thoughts um
man there was a lot said tonight
i would just say
take into consideration obviously what
it is you want as a person but what it
is that you
want from another person because
essentially if you want that
you
can't
if you want someone at this level you
can't be at this level trying to achieve
the greatest thing you can't be
i'm an athlete so i'm gonna have an
analogy in basketball you can't be the
greatest of all time if you only spend
two hours in the gym every day
so you have to do you have to put in the
work you have to be the person that you
want to attract yeah and if you want to
see us um working towards that shout out
wife school dropping soon yeah
married out here
school dropping new channel alert oh my
god
i just think that the other day if you
want people to look at you and respect
you and value a certain way
you need to set the barneys at the
standard at the end of the day and that
means
respecting yourself and not putting
yourself
like making yourself accessible to every
single person around you whether that's
any man
woman whatever it is you just need to
respect yourself
um my
my final message would be
to respect yourself respect your time
respect your energy respect your efforts
now as much as
you know the internet can oversimplify
things and say you know men good women
bad and everything everyone's just
trying their best out here
and i think
you know it starts with you respecting
yourself and being careful by the energy
and time you're investing in other
people that will avoid frustration
frustration will allow you to be more
successful with success you may learn
and grow
amen
um i'll say with reference to the
original question
uh yes
all women deserve to be courted and if
one man won't another man will hold your
head high keep moving forward because
it is what it is [ __ ]
single wait so i just quit quite just
last question i'm just curious how you'd
answer this so what do you say like the
one super chat said there's more um
women than men on the world so even if
every man was courting every woman every
woman wouldn't get courted single women
are the happiest demographic in the
world right now it's not true no no no
no no no
no no no
no it's not it's yeah i'll link it i'll
like it i'll link it and it's okay it's
women it's women okay then let me tell
you this then
should delve to
go into themselves make sure that they
are happy within themselves find things
to occupy your time find your skills
carry on building up on yourself and you
really yeah
but so but so just just quick women at
the bottom of the totem pole the ones
that like that are left they don't
deserve to be courted because there's no
one there right what do you mean like
like if there's
more women than men can take somebody
else's husband cena has so many people
wow this is so exciting
a man is going to cheat isn't it
they're going to cheat so you want that
one listen now you should marry yourself
now
oh my god
okay go to a different dimension of
logic
okay go ahead
i just think i just think after all that
i've heard today i think we all need to
learn how to set boundaries
for one
and actually just be honest with each
other
about what the other person wants
because at the end of the day all this
mind games playing is like to me i think
it's a little bit boring but we're all
different
but at the end of the day if we all just
take accountability as well
then it's fine
you can join us
okay fly on the wall
okay so i'm gonna read the final super
chats that everyone sent so um eddie e
lady in the blonde curls the chat isn't
joking drop those socials y'all throwing
around these hips like a senior citizen
great show everyone like it sometimes
they throw throw shades sometimes they
shoot their shots
hey have a great day
90 um free trow
free toe pay um why can't you let
gertrude the asian girl speak um john
the baptist my wife and i were married
in 1995 and has two grown kids i advise
my son to never marry a woman who's
non-traditional pradeep um
i'm sorry guys i'm bad at pronouncing
names um
pradeep gria to the people who argue
statistics medically if your sugar
levels are more than 140 you get
diabetes so sure some women might not
get diabetes just above beyond 140 but
pushing for exceptions is such bad
advice
dick javelin dj um how can certain women
call female objectification terrible
when they're actively selling themselves
only fans instagram twitch corn like
objects if that if is that not
not an argument that women objectify
women more than men do at this point
tristan uh oh i read that one already um
h vargas a virgin who can demonstrate to
keep it until after marriage will give
the man the confidence she can be
trusted while he's working away 80 plus
hours that's diamond platinum value
baz bundle last super chat i meant a
woman who has been
sexual and dedicated relationships only
women loses her pair bonding ability
while sleeping with a bunch of men and
will absolutely not be faithful in a
relationship
bas bundler personally i will not marry
a woman who hasn't been sexual in
ended relationships why it tells me
about her loyalty dedication decisions
despite sexual uh a pl
aplenty b it tells me she has self a
control and self worth how
eligible i just moved into my brand new
igloo my friends decided to throw me a
housewarming party now i'm homeless and
all serious is seriousness jeff's jess's
fro is looking good looking cute
thank you
lauren i thought curly hair
i thought curly hair was the one until i
saw the tongue piercing never mind drazy
and gaming
question for the panel have they heard
about the lady pro question for the
panel have they heard about the lady who
went undercover as a man for two years
then self-ended because she couldn't
live with the idea of how she was
treated as a man by women almighty tyan
curly hair is a baddie i love curly hair
on a woman it's so sexy i don't know why
probably you're killing it
um
myrtle urkel is pronounced urkel thank
you
raisin blue girl is gorgeous alexandria
tall blue sweater not to listen tell
blue sweater not to listen to all the
hate drazian gaming blue girl don't
worry i'm with you i want to die alone
too and be bitter
i can't i can't believe you the blue
lady has pushed pearl more than anyone
you obviously listen to rules or you
obviously listen to rules or anyone i
wonder why you're single um james sharp
lady in the blue it's simple marriage
material women don't mess with guys like
marriage material women don't mess with
guys like alex women having their 304
phase are drawn to guys like him big
difference the last millennial yo pearl
get hunter and linda together i love
them
alexandra
the girl in the blue is a lovely girl i
pray god will guide you and give you
direction big brown please someone
please tell blue sweater she is a three
at best recreational use only john
fairley i would like to court previous
guests like alicia or the zimbabwe oh
actually i read that one already okay i
read those
um okay guys thank you for watching the
show i think
is this the most viewers or second most
i think this might have been the second
most second okay we almost hit the most
viewers we've ever had on a stream so
we'll still crap we want to hit 4 000
live viewers so i don't know we'll see
next week um subscribe to our two clips
channel one is pearl davey and the daily
and the other is just pearly clips
sign up for our memberships we have the
five dollar tier um which we're going to
members only chat on saturday ten dollar
tier you get to see our first look at
the behind the scenes vlog of the
penthouse i also rap down there a lot of
you guys don't believe me
but i can i can
um
if if you want to see that you know ten
dollar tier um tier three is no i just
said better out oh about you rap no not
now
what had you said for a feature yeah i
want to be on a feature
tier three connect on social media tier
four um a one-on-one call with me once a
month so this can be used you know tell
me about your problems or i can help you
with your youtube channel just you know
let me know um instagram
just.purlythings and you have to put a
dot it's weird instagram does not like
put um
it doesn't put me up if yeah it doesn't
search me unless you put in the whole
thing so you have to put just dot pearly
things
um thank you for 350 subscribers
we're gonna have a members only live um
next week no
maybe
what next week or the week after
we'll see we'll see we'll see um dm
eddie if you want to come on the show
thank you for watching like the video on
your way out and we will talk to you
next time